I mean, I don't think that that Willie Slop Show actually gives
a about anything. I'll be honest with you. I think he's like
he's a mercenary and uh and I think he's just reading the room
and and realizing that this is a sinking ship that he must jump
cuz he was like actively defending.
>> Incredibly accurate call from Hassan. Let's go. >> Sweeping
for him. Apparently, Dan's now offering refunds on anything else
subs.
Maybe he feels like the money the money might not be very clean.
Okay. Wow.
>> Des be like I'm a white hat. Actually, you don't understand.
>> A hypothetical criminal case that he is
>> Okay. White hat goes so unbelievably
Dude, I solicit seam from minors so that I can prove that they're
being trafficked.
No way.
Oh my god. >> Pursuing it all. Okay.
Why was there a dead body and a bloody knife buried in my backyard?
Well, I thought if the police ever found out about the murder,
they might want to see the evidence.
Oh, Jesus.
Right. It's like It's like Okay. And also people shouldn't really
soy out about him about that excuse, right? Oh, it's like dude,
so about the crime. Okay, there's there's like actual crimes
there, right? That's the thing.
Shut it down. Trust me, I believe that's that that's cured at
this point. Okay, that's cured at this point. It has to be cured
at the point where he goes and talks to Willie Mac. Okay, and
I'm not kidding you. He goes to talk to Willy and goes, "Look
at the file name of the CP that I got from her." and takes a
VLC with the title and the date in the title 2022 20 uh sorry
2022 0814
August 14th 2022 essentially confirming in that timestamp that
she would have been a
>> and he sends a picture of the video to Willie Mac. Okay,
I don't know what
this is. This has to be like the only possible way for you to
still think Destiny is smart is you have to think Destiny has
10,000 IQ and actually he's foreseen 3,000 years into Earth's
future and he is avoiding an apocalypse of the human race by
by doing this now. Somehow this sacrifice leads like the butterfly
effect to the human race avoiding an extinction event. Okay,
that's like the only way you could possibly interpret this is
like Destiny having any control or doing anything intelligent
here. That's like the end. That's it. Okay. There's just no other
possible way. You can't cope about it anymore. It's insane. So
anyway, he sent that stuff to Willy Mack. And if you don't remember,
when he was talking to Eli, she says, "Only one of us can make
that." Oh, sorry. Actually, I've been thinking this over. She's
talking about Solo. I would like to see the police look into
this if for no reason other than he could exploiting be exploiting
other girls. Only one of us can make that happen. Want redemption,
Steven? Go to the police tomorrow and give them everything you
have. And he responds, "I have nothing to give them.
I have nothing to give them. And then we also get the Willy Mack
logs of him saying, "Look at this. Look at this video she sent
me. Look at this." From the video she sent, brother. Brother,
I don't I don't I don't know. Okay.
That's not all of it. Okay. We also have uh we have the Willy
Mack logs here. I think he sent his entire logs. I think he put
them out. Let's take a look at this real quick. Let's take a
quick
Uh, birthday would be October
2004.
October 2004. So, let's see here. August 20th, 2025. Willie Max
sends a DG Snark Snark post to Destiny saying Rose confirmed
to be 17. Hey, so I'm reading seeing this Reddit thread. Any
insights into if this is true or at all or not? If if that's
actually her or if he knew her age or not. This is going to get
bigger than it is now or bigger than it is right now. Hold on
one second. This gonna get bigger than it is right now. I mean,
she told me she was 19 and uh and she was in college when we
were chatting. Lol. If she was actually 17, then she should be
asking why that solo guy had recorded like 60 GB of with her
plus all the other guys she recorded stuff with. I'm pretty sure
even Solo said she lied about her age to me in that KF thread
somewhere. Okay. Willie responds, "I do kind of remember covering
that in my vid." Yeah, he said that you he said that you didn't
know. Lol. This is uh this is cringe, but And then he posts some
some logs here. Okay, some logs there. Is this the next Okay,
weird overlap here. Okay, so like even in our logs, I'm referring
to as a 19-year-old. I think Solo even posted these. Uh William
Max says, "In my Kelly Jean video, in my video, Kelly Gene makes
the argument that there's a message of you saying, "Do you have
an ID?" And she said, "No, Kelly never proved this to me." Surely
Destiny wouldn't go on to prove out the Twitter DMs or confirm
the Twitter DMs here, right? I actually don't recall this being
in the video, but obviously that if that pops up, that's a big
deal. I thought she showed me a student ID or something, but
I can never know about those messages because one our first ones
were on Twitter and they deleted their account. But Tinder does
some kind of Oh, you have your side of the messages though, do
you not? Would he not have if he went and did like a data dump?
Would he not have his messages?
>> I think he would, right? Wouldn't he? Uh, but Tinder
does some kind of age check. I don't remember if they This is
a lie. This is a lie. This is a lie that Willie ran with, by
the way. This is a lie that Willie ran with and supported without
doing any factchecking at all because of course Willie maybe
maybe after this conversation Willy's finally been broken out
of. Well, everything Destiny says is true. But at the time, he
was not broken out of it and he was just like, "Yeah, Tinder
apparently does some sort of age verification."
Yes, exactly. Cyberdrifter. They can do age verification now,
but they didn't do it in 2021, 2022. That's true. Yes.
>> So, he tries the same lie as before. He's trying the
same Jedi mind trick as before on Willie. And Willie says, "I
looked into this when I made my vid. I don't think that it is
require that is required." That would be horrible if you put
that in your video. Wait, what was the segment from his video?
Hold on. Am I crazy? I could have sworn in his video. He was
like, "I looked into it. It seems like they did age verify."
Hold on. There's Hold on. There's no way. Right now I have to
go find the Willie video. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Which Willie
video was it in? Number one or number two? Give me a second.
Let's find it. Oh, this music is really intrusive, though. Give
me a second. Put on some quieter instrumental only music in the
background.
There we go. >> I want to preface this video by stating
that I was >> Hold on. Okay. Confronting Destiny on his
crimes.
We have Tinder here. No, it would be in the second video, right?
The Kelly Jean video.
video where he interviews Kelly. I believe that'll be this one.
Content cop destiny >> back to the death threat in a minute.
I just want to address an >> Let's check this out. We got
uh we got Tinder here, right? >> Is wrong. >> Was
now in an impossible position.
>> Hold on. We'll find it. We'll find it. I just have to
see what Willie said. Maybe maybe I'm misremembering what Willie
said. It's possible, right? Where did my transcript just go?
Just bounced away.
>> I think Tinder to find hookups and [__]
And Tinder does um is an 18 or older app. And Destiny sent me
messages he had with Rose and her talking about using Tinder.
I haven't used Tinder in like eight years, so I don't know. Google
says it verifies age. There needs to be more tangible evidence.
Right now, the worst.
Okay, hold on
then. Willy's logs here don't really make sense. Hey, I looked
what
appears Tinder verifies age. That's what he says in the video.
What?
Tinder some I looked into this when I made my vid. I don't think
that is required. Then why did you say otherwise in your video?
Why did you just go Google says they verify age? That's like,
does that not seem weird that he just he like lied to Destiny
about what he found for his video? Or he just or he found this
and he didn't put it in the video for some reason. I looked into
this when I made my vid. I don't think that is required, but
I don't know. I haven't used Tinder in like 8 years. What do
you mean he looked into it after the video? He says, "I looked
into this when I made my video."
What? That's crazy. Do you see that? He says, "I looked into
this and I don't think that is required." The age verification
thing. But in his video he says the age verification is required.
So either he knew that at the time and he lied. He just said
well no it seems Google just says it is required which was why
would you do that or he's just lying here. I don't I don't know
which one it is. J stop. You know full well he watched a taken
to task and he's now changed his position. Well he hasn't changed
his position at all. His position is crystallized in his video.
Right. Oh no. Destiny continues.
I want this clarified. Was there ever a time you asked for her
ID because you were suspicious of her being a minor and she refused
to show you? No, I don't think so. That would have been a super
red flag. No, I don't think so. Then say, "No, you can go look
at your DMs, Destiny. You have the ability to do this." Destiny
will go on to say, "I saved all of my messages with her." You
don't have to say, "I think don't think so." You can say what
the truth is. You saved all of your messages,
right? Did you not save all of your messages? Is that not what
you said? We don't have to do what you think. We could just go
figure it out. I don't think age verification is required in
the USA. It's something you can opt into, I think. But again,
I'm not sure. Also, you never showed me her Tinder profile or
anything from it. Just say her saying she used it. Okay. Yeah,
that's also true. I'm not going to make a vid on any of this
because right now there isn't proof that you knew or are suspicious.
But if that exists, that's really bad. Like you said, super red
flag. These are all Tinder the Tinder mentions. There's no ID
mentioned in our logs. But like I said, I'm pretty sure that
first convo happened on Twitter and since they deleted the account,
I don't have access to it. I'm pretty confident if you do a full
data dump from Tinder or sorry, from Twitter as like a GDPR thing,
they would give you those messages. They would have that data
stored because I think you can undo your deletions, right?
Like you when you deactivate your account or delete it, I think
you can undo that for some amount of time. Anyway, it's kind
of crazy that there are like 10 plus parties all involved in
creating with this person if she is less than 18. And her boyfriend
Solo, the guy who I sure sounds like Desi's got to go to the
cops if he's got evidence of this, right? Like he's got evidence
of this somehow, which I think he doesn't realize. He's clearly
talking about seeing
Let's just let's just soak in what he is saying there, right?
There are like 10 plus parties all involved in creating with
this person. He is saying he has seen at least 10 different dudes
this minor. That is what he is saying. He is going That is what
he is saying there like pretty objectively. No, that's wild.
I'm just I'm just throwing it out there. That's crazy. That's
a crazy thing to say. Anyway, okay. We keep going. And how did
he get that evidence? It seems pretty clear what he's admitting
to here. Okay. I wonder if the reason the solo dude never leaked
any identifying info about her was because he was worried he'd
get caught. Bro, you're in such a weird LMFAO. I mean, if you
didn't know and you asked, then fair. She's take she's talking
about college here. Is Solo not her age? My guess is he's around
her age. I don't know 100%.
Uh, and she was in college the whole time. Yeah, but I guess
it's possible she went in one year early.
It's fun. Uh, it's fine. It was fun. Other than that, I'll see
if I can salvage any of the recordings my boyfriend made for
you. I didn't notice this until way later, but the videos she'd
record with other guys, the file names are like screen recording
blah blah blah blah blah. and this screen record
the date on it, bro.
And he sends a he sends a picture of VLC having this video open.
Now, couple things about this, okay? One, I really want to reach
out to Willie Mac. Okay? Cuz it's possible that something happened
here, okay? It's possible that when he went to go share this
image, he clicked copy link and copied that that file over, right?
If you do that in Discord, it will autombed.
But
if he's autombedding from one of those other group chats, okay,
one of the group chats that were made uh on December 3rd or December
4th,
that is to my mind, if he is sending this screen cap, that is
proof in my mind that the the group chat to find Rose exists,
right? Absolutely.
So Willie needs to go and copy link here and and put that link
publish that link on Twitter. Okay,
we need to we need to ask for this. You guys all understand what
I'm saying, right? You know what I'm talking about. Uh, Alex
Gekcko tweeted about this. Let me go find the Alex Gekcko tweet.
Who dumped these messages? Willie did. Hold on. Where's the Where's
the Alex Gekmo thing? This guy right here. Okay, so he posts
this thing from uh from KF directly. And basically like I forget
if it's blue or red, but one of these is the uh the channel ID
and you can look up through a third party site, the Snow Stamp
site, to see when the channel ID was created.
If these channel IDs matched, if if this same channel ID existed,
right, for the attachment sent to Willie,
that would be proof in my mind that this is a group chat purely
to find Rose. Why would Willie dump these messages when it doesn't
really absolve him? Because I think he knows Destiny's totally
going down. And I think he is in self-preservation mode. That
is what I think is happening here, right? I think he was perfectly
fine trading messages with Destiny. He's perfectly fine being
in that guy's camp before, but at this point, he knows that this
guy's and and this is him jumping off the boat. Okay. Yeah, this
is the rat leaving the sinking ship. Absolutely. Yes, JTO Destiny
kind of admits to this on his stream. He said he kept the videos
so we could watch them and try to find her. He's the server is
real.
Uh, dude, what's the the issue here, Jacob, is not really that
he was trying to find her, although that's weird. The issue would
be if he did have and he had reason to believe he was informed
that this person might be a minor and then he decided to disseminate
parts of those videos to people. I don't know how he is not
mega
at that point. If he did that, that is insane. That is the Destiny
Defender arc. That is it's like so beyond over at that point.
It's crazy. Yes. Yes. Yes. Really soy guy. Like if this existed
and he was posting the stuff in in there. Oh my god, that's crazy.
He knows he's that's why he ended stream early. Well, we'll have
to go take a look at that stream and see exactly what's there.
I That's
I have a hard time. Dude, we're hitting one of those poor rallies
in our shoes eight months ago now. Yeah, that's basically what
it was is you hadn't seen some of the decisions. But like here's
the thing. This was made in December. These poor decisions seem
to have been made in December. Like these are old really bad
decisions. So with Solo, the man that destroyed his career, also
his I don't I don't know what the arrangement was there. Okay,
I don't know what that what was going on there. Okay, we've gone
through a lot of these logs. Her boyfriend was recording recording
these on Skype calls. That's just absolutely insane to think
about him doing all this if she was 17. That is not a defense,
bro. And he told you she was 17, so it's not a defense to continue
to send the the video like video thumbnails of this stuff around.
Willie says, "If you're sending me this, I'm guessing you still
have that video." And Destiny immediately gets defensive. Uh,
depends on why you're asking, but yes, I created a copy of all
of our messages and everything when that court case started.
Bruh, there's been allegations since at least my last vid that
she was underage, and you still have potential CP of her. So,
this is Willie showing his IQ again. Okay, this is showing his
IQ. Bro, why didn't you just like immediately delete the evidence
of a crime? Now, I think there's a lot of things you could you
could say to Destiny here, right, about like, I don't think he
should be keeping that. I think you should probably turn that
over to the cops. You should probably turn that over to a lawyer.
You should probably I don't think you should be in possession
of that cuz obviously when he retained possession of it, he decided
he was going to disseminate parts of those videos. It seems clear
to me he just did it with Willie Mack. We have evidence of that,
right? No, I've watched the whole Trust me, Black Irish. I understand
that some states did it eventually, but it's just it's like in
2021, 2022, there was no forced age verification.
Certainly not where she was. I know that. I don't need backups
of that right now. I know. I know that for a fact.
A fact. All right, dude. The cope is going to be so funny today.
Some some logs here from DG that just got sent. Okay, Destiny,
they keep saying they won't pursue it because she's underage.
They they keep saying you won't pursue it because she's underage.
Desessie, is there any way to fight back? Desi Willy Mack throwing
you under the bus. Desi Willie is literally throwing you under
the bus. Desessie, he's saying you are sending he you are sending
you CP. Okay, this person is clearly having a meltdown and can't
type correctly. He's literally saying you sent him CP in this
video. He's literally saying you sent him CP and are hiding it.
It's Jover. He's literally accusing you of having child Hassan
is going to watch this. This is the mind of the DJer, by the
way. This is the mind.
Destiny. Hassan's definitely going to watch this and make fun
of you. Destiny, Destiny, Hassan's gonna make fun of you. Hassan,
Destiny, Hassan's gonna make fun of you.
This is This is a real This is real true messages right here.
This is like the worst case scenario, guys. Hassan gets a W.
The worst case scenario. Destiny, go over the Willy Mack vid
and get your narrative out. Destiny, yes, you need to respond
to this video. It's literally [__] insane. He completely
throws you under the bus and says you have CP. Shows a different
screenshot. Destiny, debate him. Destiny, debate him. Debate
him. Dessi, you got to debate him now. Destiny, debate him now.
It's our only option. The damage will be done. The video is [__]
insane,
bro. What is the the video is totally in line with all of the
evidence currently released that like this this Discord existed,
this Discord or Discord channel group chat existed to try to
find Rose that he was sending in there. It's all in line with
all of that stuff. It sucks cuz we can't verify that email. We
can't verify the Twitter messages, right? But there's so many
pieces of evidence around it that seem to corroborate like that
this this group chat was made. The only Willie Mack dude. Yes,
that was that was another Alex Gekcko banger today. Okay. You
guys aren't following Alex Gekkmo. I recommend. He's he's very
good. All right. I used to not be a fan of me, but hey, we we
let it all go. Okay. Which your honor have you considered that
Hassan [__] went to a brothel? My favorite part of
Destiny's stream today is when he spent 20 minutes reading what
his chat was relaying about Willy's 4-minute video instead of
watching it. He'd always been so willing to watch Willie video
videos before. Curious, dude. I don't get why Desi was looking
for Rose with that Discord crew. I have no idea, dude. I I don't
know. I legitimately don't know. He's got a ton of money. I don't
know why he wouldn't just go hire a private investigator, right?
That's one party.
What does he What did Destiny used to tell people about those
big conspiracies, the big sprawling conspiracies? Well, there's
no reason to believe that these are true or that they really
exist or that they're real. There's no reason to believe that
guys because so many people would have to be in the know that
somebody would blow the whistle, right? Like I understand you
might have a private eye, you might have a PI that you don't
necessarily trust or but like at least that's one point of failure.
You're going to start a group chat with 10 points of failure
and start linking this kind of in there. That's crazy cuz he's
light Yagami. He doesn't need help like that. Just his minions.
Well, dude. Uh
no, don't worry. Don't worry, Jake. Don't worry. We're going
to get to the VOD. We're going to get to everything. Okay, we'll
get to everything today. It's all so good. Without further ado,
though, let's actually fire this Willie video up. Let's fire
it up. Let's check it out. We went through the logs.
We'll >> report Destiny to the police. This >> I
reported Destiny to the police. All right, let's check it out.
>> I reported Destiny to the police. This is not clickbait
and entirely has to do with the DMs he sent me a few days ago.
A Reddit post showed that it will just be your pay.
donated $5. I don't get how the solo logs get into the civil
case and it's not questioned if Rose was actually a minor and
his content might be some like why wasn't that escalated in the
legal case to law enforcement? >> Um why wasn't something
escalate? Well,
oh h man, I'm just telling you I think people are very shocked
that Willie went to the cops. And I I've seen some tweets that
are saying things like, "Well, thank God that Willie finally
somebody finally went to the cops about this guy." Okay? And
all I can really say to that is, "Hey idiots,
somebody already went to the cops about this guy." Okay? Like,
please stop please stop saying like, "Oh, I I can't believe nobody's
gone to the cops." No. No. Okay. Anyway, we can we can continue.
Thank you for the five. C Samony, thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Okay. Uh I I It's shocking to me that Willie is just putting
this in his video. I feel like I can watch this. I personally
would have probably blurred this person's face out. I I legitimately
don't know. I didn't notice that. I listened to this the first
time he put this person's face on the screen. I actually feel
bad that he did that now. I don't know why he just did that.
It's Hold on. and entirely has to do with the DMs he sent me.
A few days ago, a Reddit post showed that the girl Destiny shared
Pixie's nudes with was seemingly confirmed to be 17 years old
due to her getting doxed. There is almost a 0% chance that she
was not 17 during that time. So, I >> Okay, I don't know
if he did more of this in the video. He probably just shouldn't
uh he probably shouldn't have done that. I know exactly what
his rationale would be, too, cuz I've seen some other people
say this. Okay, I don't know how to tell people this. The DG
Stark subreddit is far less public than Kiwi Farms would be.
Okay, Kiwi Farms. If you if you don't want to post evidence cuz
it's on Kiwi Farms, but you're willing to go to a subreddit with
like a 100 people following it and post evidence from there,
you're your brain is broken. You don't understand what it means
to like have privacy, right?
So, I think
I see some people run with this that it's like, oh, well, it's
on Reddit now and so I can just like talk about it. It's like,
no, no, no, no. It's on a niche subreddit. All right. And
and it's not if you if you have no qualms about posting it, you
should have no qualms going and getting it from like KF or something.
Okay, that's just facts. >> Uh Geeky Candy, thank for the
10 gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you >> for the 10.
The quick tenor. I'm going to add two hours to the stream and
I'm going to probably not worry too much about these meters for
the rest of the stream here. 5 hours 30.
Thank you very much, Geeky Candy. I appreciate it. I'll reset
those. >> What I usually do and reached out to get a comment.
He said the girl Rose told him she was 19 and in college at the
time and that the leaker Solo, who is her ex-boyfriend, confirmed
that she lied about her age to him. This is true. In similar
scandals, this is where people usually argue, is he lying? Did
he actually know the age? Is it his fault if he was catfish?
I usually wait for all the details
here. I think we have enough details to go Well, he certainly
didn't do his due diligence. He certainly he certainly didn't
actually take any precautions to make sure this wasn't the case.
All >> details to come out before I comment. This is not
why I went to the police. >> It's because Hold on. >> Uh,
soapbox Society, thank you for the 10 gifted. Appreciate it.
Appreciate it. >> Uh, I might start muting some notifications
for a little bit and maybe replaying them, guys. We'll see. Okay,
we'll see. Let me pull this back just a little bit here. >> Was
her ex-boyfriend confirmed that she lied about her age to him.
This is true. In similar scandals, this is where people usually
argue, is he lying? Did he actually know the age? Is it his fault
if he was catfish? I usually wait for all the details to come
out before I comment. This is not why I went to the police. It's
because he continued to write, "I didn't know this until way
later, but the video she recorded with other guys. The file names
are like screen recording." >> Uh, yeah. Thank you very
much for the
>> The top of a video clip and says, "Her boyfriend was
recording these on Skype calls." That's absolutely insane to
think about him doing all of this if she was 17. Well, this is
insane to me because he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP
while sending me a >> He like doesn't understand. Somehow
Destiny is like lost the ability to understand that like once
you're notified she might be under 18 that like continuing to
share any elements of these videos is probably [__]
to do. >> God just tipped $5.
They're the proof that enlightened atheism isn't a path to moral
behavior.
Lucifer is waiting for his new playmate.
>> Thank you. Thank you for that. We're going to actually
turn the donos down for the rest of the stream. Well, for at
least a little bit. I'll maybe go back and play them two hours
or something. Remind me. I'll go back and play all of the donos.
I'll replay them all. But thank you very much. Okay. Thank you
very much, God. Appreciate it. I'm going to turn it I'm going
to turn the donuts down. I just want to be able to go through
this stuff. Okay. So, that that interrupts sometimes. I do appreciate
all the money. I'm not angry at you guys. Thank you very much
for donating, but I do want the content to flow. And it is it
is a little hard to have it flow when the donors are coming in.
That's all. If you want to wait until I'm actually going through
donos to donate, that's also fine. Really appreciate you guys.
Love you guys. All right. Going back. >> Recording these
on Skype calls. That's absolutely insane to think about him doing
all of this if she was 17. Well, this is insane to me because
he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP while sending me a of
the alleged CP. So, I asked to confirm if he just did that. If
you were sending me this, I'm guessing you still have that video.
Best depends on why you're asking, but yes, I created copies
of all of our messages and everything when that court case started.
Just to be clear, he's admitting to having alleged CP downloaded
on his computer. He literally has the video open as I'm talking
to him. I go I believe there is basically every reason to believe
this before the Willy Mack DMs came out, right? Like we knew
he had of her. We knew he talked about having downloading of
her of viewing it, right? And asking her for more. All of those
logs existed. You put that together with the fact that she was
17 at the time of the DMs. It's not hard to understand what happened,
right? These DMs factually don't add very much that it is stark
though. I will say I do appreciate that it is stark here that
you get him sending the images, right? You get him actually sending
these images, actually showing that yes, I did indeed. Oh, I'll
turn it up for you guys. I did indeed keep these videos and I
am propagating like more details like screen caps, screen caps
from them, titles from them, >> Oh, bro, there's been allegations
at least since my last video that she was underage and you still
have potential CP of her. He replies, I have an obligation to
preserve relevant evidence except >> this is this is the
moment the moment where Willie M Willie Mac's conditioning broke.
Okay, this is the moment he realized he had to flee the plantation.
Was like, "Dude, I
I said that you she might have been underageed. Like, and you
still kept the port of her? You're like you you're like sending
me screen caps of the port of her?" And he he like it actually
broke and he like realized, "Oh, oh [__] maybe this
guy isn't right about everything, etc." So, I created backups
of all of the important/relevant conversations. He continues,
"I don't think I'm allowed to delete it, lol. I don't know if
it counts as hiding/destroying evidence." and I replied, "Talk
to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me." >> Who keeps this
sort of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing if they're
supposed to or not? Isn't that something you want to confirm?
>> Oh my god. Could you imagine if Andy B didn't know about
this stuff? Could you imagine? Do you guys think Andy B knows?
>> I continued. You just let me know you have CP videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still have them. Do you see how this is? So now
I've confirmed that this guy has child on his computer. In my
eight years of reaching out to people over allegations, I've
never had anyone admit that to me. The last message he sent me
was one. I don't even know 100% of her age was legitimately less
than 18 when these were taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure
if he has child on his computer. He's just 99% sure. Got it.
Two, I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to preserve, >> dude.
Uh, and as I pointed out, okay, I did this on on Twitter. So
as as was pointed out the date stamp on the video is literally
literally from after she or sorry before she was 18. So he says
I don't know but then when you look at the video title it says
August 14th 2022.
So if that date that if it's if 104 if October 20 October 2004
is actually her birthday her birth month then she's absolutely
a minor in this screen recording and he knows that and he is
still sending the title from it and not paying any attention
to what he's sending. By the way the date of these DMs is August
20th. Like Willie is saying hey it seems to be proven that she's
17 now. What the [__] dude? And instead of like doing
anything to look into this, validate anything, he just goes,
"Well, here's a video from August 2022 where like I don't know
if she was 18 here." No, you do know that if assuming this isn't
all, you know, assuming the 0001% chance isn't there that this
is all like somehow elaborately made up, right? You do know that
she's 17. You do know that she's a minor. You literally know
that. He's probably rock hard when he's sending them, so probably
not thinking about Jesus Christ. Geeky Candy. Jesus.
Holy. Huh. So like even the things he's saying to Willie directly
are like either lies or he has lost the ability to like he's
lost the ability to evaluate this situation at all. >> Stuff
related to my court case. I've talked about it with my lawyer
already specifically with regards to the road stuff. So he went
from I don't know if I >> So he says he told Andy B about
it. Okay. He says he told Andy B and Andy B said you hold on
to that CP buddy. Now, what I'm less certain Andy B would have
said was you hold on to that CP and if you need to disseminate
that to a group of a dozen people, not including you, if you
need to do that, then that's okay, too. You just go ahead and
disseminate that bad boy. Okay? You hold on to it and then you
send it to whoever you want. I'm pretty sure Andy B didn't tell
him this. If I had to guess, I'm pretty sure Andy B is going
to be pretty pretty contankerous to find out that Destiny was
sending screen caps and/or clips from these videos to people
in a group chat. Okay? There's no universe a lawyer would ever
tell him to hold on to it. I don't know, Benji. I don't know
for 100%. Okay. But to me, I don't know why you would do that
on a personal level. I don't know why you wouldn't go to the
cops if you suspected this, right? And say, "Hey, uh, like that
to me feels like the way to do this." What what actually happens
when he says like, "Oh, I was told I could do this." And he holds
on to it. In my mind, it's very obvious what he's trying to do
is not get in trouble for deleting evidence if it does come out
that she's 18, but also not report it to the cops and potentially
get himself in trouble if she is under 18, right? He's trying
to avoid getting caught and not get if he does get caught, he's
trying not to have evidence deleted so that if he does get caught,
like he's trying to play both sides of it, right? Obviously,
the the clear and honest obvious answer to everybody is the moment
you find out she might have been below 18, you go to the cops
for the exact reason that he's soying out about on Twitter and
pretending is like his cover, right? For that exact reason that
Solo could have been trafficking this girl. Solo could be exploiting
this girl, right? And you don't know and you absolutely are compelled
to go to the cops in this situation. Let me go to this thread.
Right? That's that's the precise reason you have to go to the
cops as soon as you get some indication that she was under 18.
Now, I'm just talking morally,
right? I don't know if there's a legal obligation to do that.
I would think so, but I don't know for sure. Okay. I don't know
for sure. It's finally over. It really is finally over, isn't
it? It really is over. It's all He's already been visited by
the FBI. Doesn't that mean he probably lied to them? I don't
know what the That was him talking about it in his chat and [__]
Okay.
Uh he did blame me for that call apparently,
dude. Dude, at the very least, it sounds like he didn't check
with his lawyers after we found out she was a minor.
Dude, I nothing he's doing is with legal knowledge or with like
legal advice. There's just no way, right? Like, it seems pretty
clear to me that there's just no way you could think that. So,
do you think Destiny is going to get the death penalty in Florida
for C7 being a No, I don't think he'd get the death penalty.
Are you Are you trying to like str I don't I don't even know.
I think the the dream has materialized. Okay, that this is the
dream. Oh, just being funny. Okay. Okay. The the dream is materialized
though. Okay. The dream is materialized. I believe it. It's possible.
Okay. Some some registry might be possible. Possibly. Okay. Wait,
wait, wait, wait. What is Vigilance Stream saying? Uh, Vigilance
Stream.
He said, "I doubt he did anything criminal with respect to Rose."
Wait, Vigilance Stream, after he was after he was told by people
that she was under the age of 18, he apparently propagated pieces
of these videos into a group chat. Would that not be pretty clear
dissemination of CSAM? That seems pretty obvious to me. Unless
you talk about Solo. I actually missed your first message. So,
I wonder how it's going to look to a jury. The fact that he's
embroiled not only in the revenge, but now this at the same time.
Yeah. I bro, he's not making himself sympathetic to a jury, is
he? He was told by the producer of the Cam, not just people.
That's also true. Yes. Oh, vigilance stream. Maybe I've seen
some people argue that
knowledge is required under the federal statute, that it's not
just a statutory statute, right? I've seen some people argue
that. I do believe there's a there's a Florida statute that is
not that is not required that. But in any case, like I can we
can let judges or or cops or whoever look into that. I don't
really I don't know. I haven't looked into it yet. We could maybe
look into it later. Good message by Dung Devil. What is this?
Hold on. Hold on. I mean, that's using an email that we can't
for confirm is real, but uh we'll see. We'll see. I'll I'll look
into that stuff a little bit later, guys. We should go through
the Willie video. Okay, let's get back to it. Let's get back
to it case. I've talked about it with my lawyer already, specifically
with regards to the Rose stuff. So, he went from I don't know
if I could delete this to my lawyer says it's totally fine to
keep. I don't know the law, but the idea that his lawyer would
tell him to hold on to CP for a civil case just doesn't seem
likely to me. I don't know. Law Tube can figure that out. Three,
if something were to come out of this, I don't know if I'd want
to wipe everything and not have something to turn over to the
authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political creator
is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about to hear
some weird. If hypothetically her
boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her or getting
her to other dudes on video for him, and if there was ever some
kind of investigation into that, am I hurting the chance of looking
into him by deleting all of this stuff? Oh, so now the reason
he's keeping the CP is because of a hypothetical criminal case
that he is not pursuing at all. Okay. Maybe these >> and
and realistically if you've known right if you known she might
have been 17 I think you're you are morally required to pursue
that case then right if you think well cuz he's had this thought
in his head for a while. Well if uh if she is underage then uh
Solo is a really bad guy. Okay why didn't you go to the cops?
You can't you can't virtue signal over what a bad guy Solo must
be and also hold this evidence all to yourself hoping that it
never really blows up. That's wild. That's a wild practice to
>> these reasons are legally sound advice that came from
his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and just saying anything to make
it sound better to me. I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I just
know this guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 gigabytes
according to him. Seriously, how does he know the amount if he
doesn't have it? Also, how does her boyfriend being in the wrong
somehow >> See, I know Destiny must have watched parts
of this video or he must have been talked parts of this video
must have been talked about cuz he gives evidence for this, right?
He just gives evidence for this one piece. >> Destiny in
the right. It makes no sense. For all he knows, her boyfriend
could have been 17 as well. Dude, you were 33. I reported this
to the police and recorded my interactions and calls with the
detective. >> Uh, William, how you doing as officer?
>> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great
question. >> Sure. have screenshots or copies of the >> of
what you guys spoke about having teleport and all that. >> I
also sent them my DMs with Destiny. I don't know if anything
will come from this. I don't like leaking DMs as me respecting
what creators want on and off the record allows me to talk to
all sides of the situation builds trust with the creator and
also allows me to get >> By the way, just to be clear,
I Oh, man. I This is very interesting. Okay. Damn, he's stressed
AF. Destiny. Uh, he definitely is. He's definitely like been
leaking a whole bunch of stuff. [__] me. I dude >> followup
statements for when the drama develops. But when you tell me
that you're in possession of and going to remain in possession
of C. >> Well, that is funny.
Anna. Well, that is funny. Okay. We don't talk about Nathan here.
So, keep it to yourself. Okay. Don't We don't talk about I understand
it's funny. I understand it's difficult. Okay. Oh, Willie stressed.
I see what you're talking about, Dorothy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
see it. I see it. I got >> EP that confidentiality is over.
I shouldn't even need to say that. If Destiny ends up being legally
in the right to keep it, then fair enough. If he ends up getting
charged, then I'm glad I did something. I'm just trying to do
the right thing in a situation I've never been in before. >> Okay.
Well, will he call the cops? Um, I do believe you could call
the cops yesterday, the day before. Um, I know that the cops
have been notified with regards to Destiny's crimes. Okay. I
know things have been reported. We all know this. We've all We
all know this. Okay. We all know it. There will be a H.
We move we move forward. Okay. Where are we? What is this? All
right. Give Willy something. What do you mean give Willie something?
Stalin. I mean, he gets credit for doing what I think he was
mandatorily legally required to do here. I do believe he gets
that credit. Yeah, 100%. Give me two seconds here. Yeah, I know.
I know, guy. Guys, the anoke joke was funny, but we we still
have the same principle. Okay, same principle applies. It's going
to keep applying. All right, going to keep applying. So, Destiny
was obviously rattled today, not just from the Willie video,
but from a lot of stuff. He um he suggested he made some suggestions,
okay, about how sorry, he made some very open-ended suggestions
about how to stop people like Quimman or I. All right, maybe
All right, I'm not going to speak too much in that direction
for now. Okay, but we have these uh these these logs from Destiny
here earlier this morning. Okay, I thought this was um I thought
this is pretty crazy. All right, I I thought this was pretty
crazy. Ma Katarina in DG chat says, "I feel like Jtock and Queen
will never stop and they have no content of their own, so they
can dedicate 24/7 to this. Not sure how one would stop that."
Okay, that's responds. Mila Katarina, uh it'll just come down
to other communities, especially this one, not being
about everything. She says, "True was unbelievable how quickly
people ran with old KF info."
Not old at all. Was not old. Was not old at all. And
see, this is the part of the spin, but it's fine. Okay. Redhead
says, "Destiny, when you say not being, what do you mean exactly?"
Genuinely curious. Katarina follows up. I just hate Jtock and
want him destroyed. Wow. Fair. Uh, Redhead, you know what I mean,
baby.
Destiny, when you say not being, what do you mean exactly? Genuinely
curious, you know what I mean, baby. Destiny, in my heart of
hearts, I do. Daddy07.
Uh-huh. I don't Dude, I don't uh I like this pretty this pretty
wild. Okay. And people would maybe compare this I think people
would want to compare this to the Queenman Max Striker thing,
right? Where it's like somebody says, but that's not what's happening,
right? Destiny is opening this up and saying something's got
to be done about these people. And other people are filling the
blanks and he's going, "Yeah, buddy. Yeah, you know, you know
what has to be done." Like, "Huh? People need to stop being such
when it comes to these guys." Huh? What do you mean? You know
what I mean? I do know what you mean, right?
That's
that's crazy.
That's That's crazy. And it's not close to what uh what happened
with Queenman. It's not close to anything Hassan's done. There's
just no there's no equating what he's doing, what he's actively
campaigning and doing to any other creator, right? He is just
openly calling for other creators to get killed. He's pointing
his audience at them. He's trying to, right? And I think this
is indicative of his state of mind that he has a obviously he
knows he's pretty, right? Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. Read
my last message. Hold on. Vigilant stream. Give me a second.
I trust you. By the way, to clarify, DG misrepresentation. Traffic
cases of minors are not sealed in Illinois. The fact that the
case is public does not mean she was an adult. Furthermore, the
traffic violation resulted in a civil case in which Rose's mother
was served. This only happens if she was a minor. She was 100%
under 18. Oh, that's actually super helpful. Vigilant stream.
Thank you.
Yeah. So, her mother was served instead of her for a traffic
violation. I'm guessing that the ticket wasn't paid. And that
only happens if she's below 18. Oh, so that's like game, set,
match. That's game ball. That's That's it. That's It's over.
It's Is it over? Might be over. Destiny is booking a flight to
Canada as you speak. Uh, I think he's probably booking a flight
somewhere else. Okay. Preferably somewhere with a very very restrictive
extradition policies. Okay. Possibly Israel. Possibly Israel.
Look at B. Yeah, I know about the bad empanada tweet. I know.
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know all about it. One second.
Oh [__] One second here, guys. Sorry. I'm back. I'm
back. I'm back. Hello. Um, isn't the Tinder proves she is over
age as good as saying the minor was holding a beer, therefore
it's normal to assume 18 plus? Yeah, basically. Is it even that
strong? It's It's probably That's about the same thing, Libogans.
Yeah, that like you see somebody holding a beer and you're like,
"Well, they wouldn't have served her alcohol." It's it's the
exact case that like statutory laws get put in place for, right?
Why is the next message of Destiny not included in this? Probably
because I went and grabbed it myself. Zezy, what's the next message?
Give me a sec. What is that next message, Zezy? I'm sure you
would have sent it to me. Give me a second. Oh, cuz I didn't
want to include it. That's why. Yeah, I just didn't want to include
it. That's why. You actually need an ID to buy a beer, unlike
making a Tinder account. You know what? When you're right, you're
right. Not your address.
Not your address. Not your I don't know how to say your name,
but when you're right, you're right. Okay.
Uh or a Twitter account. Yes. Non-ageverified platforms. Without
further ado, though, we might as well just get right into this.
Um, this is what he's neoc. Okay, hold on. I believe this is
about somebody else. But yes. Okay. I think this I think this
clip you're about to send me is about there way for us to help
in general. Yeah. If you see something, say something. Unironically,
if you see people spreading or lies or misinformation,
um, you should uh, post about it or call them out on Twitter.
Say, "Hey, that's not true." Or do the debate bro thing. Say
source source source source source source. Do that. Hit him up
with a source. Is there any way for us? >> Okay. apable
of showing I know it's about keles.
Oh, I see. I see what you're saying. Yeah. I mean, this used
to be how that community functioned, right? Proof. As soon as
Destiny flipped from being the person in the right ostensibly
to the person in the wrong, he lost all of his principles. Yeah,
we've covered this for sure. All right.
Okay. Willy M video was
good, and I'm happy about the wave it's setting off. Okay. Let's
check this out. He clicks over onto this thread right here. All
right. and he basically rants about this whole thing the whole
day when the worst person you know makes a crazy tweet. Okay,
hold on. Hold on. I can't do bad empanada tweets on stream. I'm
going to have to read this and then recall it from memory. Hold
on. Based on my very good memory. Okay. Channeling trying to
remember what bad empanada last tweeted. It was something like
breaking Trump had been looking to hire Steven Destiny Bennell
for new child safety commissioner position. Wow. It's amazing
how we can recall things like that, isn't it? It's amazing. Amazing.
All right, let's get let's get to this vlog. He's basically gonna
go on a rant for I think like an hour or two here.
Um yeah, let's let's check it out. Let's check it out. Let's
see. Let's see what's going on. I think Connor's standing by
his statements two days ago. Yeah, I don't think Connor's I I
think Connor has decided he's like uh totally buried. He's totally
embedded down.
All
our buddy's back on it today, guys. The number the number one
guy. the number one guy. He's out here just covering everything
again right away. Let's go. Hassan is good. We love Hassan right
now. Okay. Hassan just going through a thread. Let's go. Let's
go. Did you get the stream from Connor? He said he was going
to dispute the copyright strike. I don't think that's going to
get me the stream, though. We'll just have to know to to archive
stuff better this time. Okay.
Dude, this is awesome. This is awesome. This is awesome. Okay,
we love Hassan here, guys. We love Hassan. Han is awesome. Hassan
didn't do nothing. Okay. Han can do no wrong sometimes. Okay,
in case you uh hadn't followed anything on the uh in the online
world, there's been some uh been some uh meme drama going on.
So, supposedly
uh the person I was chatting with in 2022
who's uh you guys can think of it this way. Okay, you guys can
think of it this way. I'm not sure who occupies more space in
Destiny's mind between these two people, but you could think
of it this way. Okay, realistically, haven't the clues always
been there? Hasn't Hassan always known just an insane amount
about Destiny's like niche drama? Even when Destiny was like
a smaller creator, Hassan was like massive. Hasn't Hassan always
known a lot. I believe the signs were there the whole time that
this may be the case. Okay, so you can just say Hassan won. All
right, and we'll know what you mean. Hassan won. Hassan won.
whose account got taken over, hacked, compromised,
logged into by her boyfriend, ex-boyfriend. I have no idea. I
don't know if I'll ever know the answer to that. Um, somebody
from Kiwi Farm said that they found a parking ticket or a traffic
ticket of hers. And the they the 1004 apparently means that this
chick was 17 when she messaged me.
So, to be clear, it's not just the 104. It's also the fact that
her mother was served the notice to appear in court instead of
her, right? She is not an adult yet. She cannot appear in court
for herself. So, her mother was served, right? Let's not do too
much misinformation. She's absolutely a minor in this case >> her
telling me that she was 19 um despite her having 18 plus rate
on her profile, whatever else. So, that's been the uh the memes
recently on that rose check. I will say that uh if she lied to
me about her age, it's pretty crazy that her boyfriend at the
time was just I guess pumping out crazy amounts of Oh, apparently
apparently in 2021, she ran a red light. In 2022, the person
she hit while the civil case, both her and her mother were served.
So, served by the state originally only served the mother. Hold
on, hold on. Rose ran a red light and hit someone. She got a
traffic citation for running the red light in 2022. The person
she hit filed a civil case. Both her and her mother were served.
Sorry. Both her and her mother were served. The mother would
only be served if she was a minor. >> Okay. All right.
>> What do you call it? A cam, I guess, with her. I don't
know if anybody has >> That's Now, I haven't looked into
that. Sorry. I should make it very clear. I'm reading chat messages.
I haven't looked into that, but that is what Vigilance Stream
is telling me. Usually looks into stuff pretty closely. Okay.
Appreciate that guy >> into that or if anybody cares about
that, but that's where those uh
that's where those memes are at. >> So, again, you guys
could say, "Oh, the mom owns the car." But if she was served,
if Rose herself was served with the traffic citation, why would
they go to the mom when the mom is uninvolved? Unless she's a
minor. >> Right now, I have um
maybe something to do with insurance. No idea. I never found
any information on him and nobody ever cared to look for him
because they only care about tagging me down. >> Actually,
Destiny is the person who has hoarded all information on this
guy and not looked for him himself. who said because of Pixie.
Oh my god. Thank god Destiny just Destiny can refute all of Destiny's
points. Thank god for Destiny here. Okay, where's the where's
the point about Yes. So Eli asks like why aren't you going after
this guy? And he says was in the process of doing that with my
law firm in NYC, but the random random extortion lawsuit with
that Pixie decided to drop on me plus everyone else trying to
push their own agenda on this has exhausted my ability to do
so. So basically because Pixie is mean to him, he actually can't
go after this guy who he is now trying to frame as the biggest
scumbag here. Now that could be true. That guy could be a massive
scumbag. All right. But he's blaming Pixie while hoarding all
of the information he has here. He now believes there's a criminal
thing. Shouldn't he be going to the cops himself and saying,
"Hey cops, I think I have evidence of a crime. He should have
done it before. I don't know what what possible logic he could
do now to justify not going to the cops." Right? He has to go
to the cops and say, "Hey, I have evidence of a crime."
He has to do it. He is the person with all of the evidence about
who Solo is. All of it. And then he goes, "Well, it appears that
just nobody cares about this guy."
Why? Also, oh my god, there's just so many things
going beyond that even. Why has he only leaked things about Rose?
Why has he leaked anything about Solo? Sorry, let's let's roll
it back here. >> Never found any information on him and
nobody ever cared to look for him because they only care about
taking me down. Yeah, I watched Hassan do like a uh I watched
Hassan do like a eight hour read through of my entire recent
Kiwi Farms thread on >> and you're worried about copyright
infringement. I think I think he's worried about like uh you
know Hassan stealing his IP copyright infringement. Destiny is
the only person who reads Destiny's Kiwi Farms thread on stream.
Hassan, you can't do that. Hassan, Hassan,
stop on his stream the other day, which I thought was kind of
interesting listening to him uh read through leaked and
um one other person. >> Destiny would never leak. Could
you imagine doing something so disgusting? Destiny would never
do that. He would never leak. Those are private and personal
and they should never be used to ridicule somebody else.
So true.
has like leaked messages from me before and some people are like
conflating some of these messages as being from the same person
and random [__] Um, I don't really feel like reading
off my messages on stream. I think it's kind of chill or not
chill. I'm sorry. Just that's not what I meant. I think it's
kind of cringe. Can't you just chill with women, dude? Um, so
I've said this and I'll say it again. Like guys, 2025 I've cut
all the toxic people out of my life. I've cut them all out of
my life. Apparently that means just everybody, right? I've cut
literally everybody out of my life. Everybody was toxic. Everybody
who doesn't just one to one spit out the exact things I say and
think I'm the victim in every single situation. Okay? Those are
the rules. You have to think I'm the victim at all times. You
have to constantly support me no matter what I do or else I'm
cutting you out. So Connor can stay. Arrodite can stay. Although
I wonder if Arerodite's even there anymore. I actually don't
know. Haven't seen any I haven't seen any post from her recently.
She went from going like, "Stephen thinks I'm really smart and
really good at debate and like we're 50/50 business partners
actually like a month ago and now what's going on? We just got
radio silence." >> All of this is from the leak back in
2022. They just keep finding ways to redig it up and refresh
it and find whatever other new
>> No, they didn't. They didn't just find ways.
Could you imagine framing it this way? Did people just keep digging
up my 2022 and finding new ways to make it drama? That's not
what happened. Let's not let's not pretend that we don't know
exactly what happened here, Destiny. People didn't dig up random
stuff. You dropped additional PII on rows to taunt your Kiwi
Farms Alogs to taunt the people in your Kiwi Farms thread directly
and that led to this person being doxed and us finding out that
you were a minor. That's what actually happened.
Oh [__] His hours have gone up massively, haven't
they? But that's that's what actually happened. Destiny himself
leaked this info and got her doxed and has done this all to himself.
Okay? He can't say, "Oh, well, people just decide to keep bringing
this up for no reason." That's not true. That's not true. You
gave the pivotal pieces of information, the pivotal pieces of
evidence for the people who you say ruined your life to find
this woman. You did that, Destiny. um thing they can I guess
about it, but they really farm that kiwi, huh? Yeah. >> How
imagine being a DGER and not understanding
that the only reason there's any farming going on, the only reason
we know about this is because Destiny intentionally and said
this intentionally leaked information, private information about
somebody he was as a minor to taunt people who he says ruin his
lives, who when you play footsies with these people, lives get
ruined, right? and he leaked that information for those people
and got them docks and found out that this person was a minor
and he was minor and he is painting this as well these people
really farm this wow this is just totally random they're just
bringing up old news that's not what happened
um that's really all there is for that the um
is this all from
mods and well it's from the kiwi farms thread and then that it's
the same thing as before from the kiwi farms thread and then
it filters up to >> okay I I'll be real. This one is the
Kiwi Farms thread filtering up to people. But that's that's not
my fault. I don't I don't say, "Well, I won't look at Kiwi Farms
for information, right? I've never said that. I've said I won't
go go and take like narratives from Kiwi Farms." This is not
a narrative, right? This is not a narrative. The we we're not
doing the genetic fallacy here. We do not think information is
invalid to talk about just because it comes from Kiwi Farms.
That's apparently despite the entire Keles arc. That's apparently
like Destiny's thing now. Okay, I'm a Hassan mod,
dude. I don't
It's crazy. This one did filter up from Kiwi Farms, but unfortunately
for for Destiny, a bunch of people once this is proven like we
don't have any problem talking about facts. We don't zero zero
problems.
Ethan Ralph is your source. Lol. No.
>> Justical and everybody else. And now obviously they
all want to do debates and talk about it constantly. So, so if
I understand this correctly, people are assuming the age. Does
anyone know her actual age? There there's a ticket that was found
like some traffic ticket that purports that she the 1004 means
that she was born in October of 2004. If that is the case, for
some reason, they didn't check the juvenile box on the ticket.
But, I mean, I don't have because the site the the form for the
site is like her profile. Her profile doesn't tick juvenile because
she is no longer a juvenile. It's not all the page for the ticket.
That is a part of her profile. She's not a juvenile currently,
right? So that that tick that check box is not ticked. If you
had someone who's a juvenile currently, that would be
>> I don't know who this person is, I guess, like in terms
of their birth records or anything. I don't have any of that
information, and I have no way to access information. So, um,
didn't she have a Tinder account, too? Uh, yeah. I mean, like
I said, this like I had every reason to believe this person was
old. >> You did not have every reason.
They >> Hold on. Hold on. I want him to list every reason.
Okay. every reason he thought she was above 18 and then we can
do the reasons. Let's just do a a comparison. Okay, the reasons
she was above 18 and the reasons she was below 18 or might be
below 18. All right, let's let's see what his reasons are for
that she would be above 18 and I have no way to access information.
So, didn't she have a Tinder account, too? Uh, yeah. I mean,
like I said, this like I had every reason to believe this person
was older than 18. They were in college. They had a Tinder account.
Um, the um I mean they sold NASA work material on Twitter. Do
you have to be 18 to do any of those things? Is there any requirement
to be 18 to do any of those things in 2022? Bro, I had no reason
to think she was a minor. I mean, uh, sorry. Uh, an adult. Sorry.
Yeah, I had no reason to think she was a minor. She like, uh,
she totally like drank beer before. She described what beer tasted
like. How could I possibly think she was a minor if she knows
what beer tasted like? Really? She wasn't correcting him. Oh,
also she told me she was not a minor. Oh, we've got we've got
Easy96 here. He's doing the
He's doing the Leon the Professional bit. Hold on. Let's uh let's
go grab that tweet really quickly. We've got Easy96 here doing
uh a the best narrative. Okay, this is the best one,
guys. There's no reason to believe she was a minor because she
said she was
>> Want to see my license? >> No, just look a little
younger.
>> Wow. Wow, guys. She she didn't say that she was a minor.
>> Supposedly they recorded a ton of stuff with their boyfriend.
They said who I pretty sure is the guy who leaked stuff. Uh although
I don't know that 100%. I don't know if I'll ever know that 100%.
But can't you still subpoena her? Well, that would have to be
for a totally separate court case that I would pursue. Uh I'm
still not 100% on if I'll do
um related to that. Why not, Destiny? I thought that guy was
the real bad guy here. He's the guy who leaked your revenge.
And you think he was trafficking underage girls?
Isn't that the exact guy you should go after? Isn't that who
all of your rage should be directed at? Why do you have Why do
you have rage for Pixie when she was wronged by you? And no rage
for this guy. You won't even go after this guy. You'd rather
you'd rather spend all of your money on Andy B for the Pixie
case than go after that guy?
Seriously, that's crazy. That's a crazy prioritization.
>> just because of the because all of the one, all the
money I'm spending on the pixie case, and two, I don't even know
if it'd be worth it at this point, if there's any like I don't
know if there's anything to be gained from going down that road.
But I'll maybe I'll see when this my Pixie thing is over. Yeah,
like this is another place where it's just the rational self-interest
isn't kicking in. Like, how is he not trying to go to the cops,
man? I don't know. It's crazy. Anyway, so he says, "Oh, I was
spending too much money on the Pixie case." Well, Pixie didn't
wrong you. Pixie wanted like, "Dude, he could have gotten out
of the Pixie case for less than his legal fees." Almost certainly
could have gotten out of the Pixie case for less than his legal
fees. And he's just decided to continue that on. >> Another
fantastic point is it does not cost money to go to the police.
Aren't you guys glad I came up with that? I don't know if you
could hear the other voice. Yes, it costs no money to go to the
police. Go to the police. Just go to the police. No, that was
just me doing a voice, guys. That was just me doing a voice.
It doesn't cost any money to go to the police. Okay,
sorry. We continue. >> They keep saying uh you won't pursue
anything because she's underage. I don't know why it would matter
if I would pursue anything or not. >> Uh you have all of
the evidence about who this guy is and the crimes that were committed
and you could go to the police. Why won't you go to the police?
That doesn't cost you money. Just go to the police. Just go to
the police. Just go to the police. Just go to the police. Bro,
the
there's some weird asymmetry in the eyes here that's bugging
me out. What is this? Is it just the lighting? Maybe it's just
the lighting. This eye is like way bigger. I >> um if she
if that is the case. I mean there's always people that can investigate
and look into that. Apparently that's what they're doing now.
So has this transcript still not been unsealed?
>> Uh nope. It is not. It is not.
And funny enough, a lot of the legal people who have looked at
this are like, "Yeah, it seems like this guy's just totally willfully
neglecting the current seal on that transcript." Right? Like
I I've heard at least two lawyers now say it seems likely that
his violation of the seal is probably the thing that will guarantee
it is now actually sealed. Like him willfully negle willfully
ignoring the court order, the court mandate to keep that sealed,
going and reading it publicly on a stream, right? Word for word
verbatim from the transcript is very likely the thing that will
leading to it being permanent will lead to it being permanently
sealed and possibly lead to further sanctions on him or his lawyers,
right? Like there's a concept of making it attorney's eyes only.
F future information about the case might get set to attorney's
eyes only as in Destiny wouldn't be able to see it anymore because
of his willful fl uh his what would you call it? Flouting. His
willful flouting. His flagrant flouting of the legal system of
the of the judge's rulings. Okay. Uh
what is this? Also, somebody archived this episode. Give me a
second. What is this? What is this? What is this? What is this?
Oh, also yeah, we should watch the west. We should watch the
west bit. >> Messaging a minor and it would
>> sometimes lead to
>> Yeah, we've we've covered this like a thousand times.
Sorry. We will maybe we'll go through all of the doctor disrespect
stuff where he talks about how he doesn't care about messaging
a 17-year-old. Okay, but yes, he said it a thousand times. Still
just waiting
there. I'm also going to pull this back and uh use a bathroom
real quick. Need to get some water. I'll be right back.
They keep saying uh you won't pursue anything because she's underage.
I don't know why it would matter if I would pursue anything or
not. Um, if she if that is the case, I mean, there's always people
that can investigate and look into that. Apparently, that's what
they're doing now. So, has the transcript still not been unsealed?
Uh, nope.
We're still just waiting.
Um, the last filing on the case is again, all Pixie does now
is she just basically refreshes or has Lauren refresh that Kiwi
Farms thread every single day to try to find anything. And I
was chatting with food shops I think like three days ago
um about one of Pixie's answers in court which I thought was
really funny, really stupid. And then they heard that and then
they >> Oh guys, it's it's really bad that they keep an
eye on the things I do and report them accurately to the court.
By the way, they don't make any they don't mischaracterize the
exact thing they say he did, right? They say he read verbatim
from the transcript. That is their accusation. If Destiny was
just recollecting, maybe he gets away with it. If he was reading
verbatim from that transcript, I think he's pretty like, why
does he why does he say this? Like, oh, they're they're just
following the KF thread and they just do whatever they want from
the KF thread. Bro, you read a sealed document. The entire purpose
of the seal is to evaluate for them to evaluate whether or not
that can be released. You intentionally flouted the court order.
That is something they should bring up. That is something they
should actually do a motion on 100% of the time. Just stop.
Hold
on. I need the clip. I need the clip. I need the clip. I need
the clip. >> Oh, busted skull. He knocked over. >> Stop
breaking the law, [__]
>> Just every time it just hits the same every single time.
Stop breaking the law. Stop. Just stop. And your problems go
away. Stop.
No, Destiny. Don't send that cam to a group of 10 people. Don't
do it. Stop. Just stop. Just stop. Just stop. My lawyer. They're
like, "We're going to file an emergency motion because you're
destroying our blah blah blah." It's like, okay, so that's just
them filing more and more motions. Um, the thing a lawyer friend
told me, I don't know how true this is or if it matters or not,
but supposedly
uh court dockets that are really busy
um just look like there's more stuff that's being contested,
which makes you less like which makes a judge less likely to
do anything um to solve resolve a case on summary judgement.
So, it just lets them drag it out longer and longer. Um,
I don't know if they would actually go to trial on this, like
if that's their goal. I mean, it could be. Uh, I don't know if
I care that much. I mean, other than just wasted money. I'm at
this point I'm incredibly confident uh on my side of things.
Like, there's a reason why that girl is dodging our attempts
to sub her and our attempts to depose her. Um, I'm pretty confident,
guys. Just the entire universe is going after this guy. All right?
He didn't do anything wrong, but he just has he he just can't
prove it. Okay? He's in a legal case, so he can't talk about
the Rose stuff at all. He can't talk about any of these leaks.
He can't talk about anything, guys, because he's in a legal case.
Yeah, he did share a whole bunch of that like 10 person group
chat. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Sure. But like, dude, why
is everybody going after him? I can't I'm trying to like there's
just no throughine. I' I've explained this already. There's no
rational throughine for for all of the positions he's had. There
is no rational through line at all. But they have nothing on
this, but they're just trying to drag it out for as long as possible.
Uh, somebody asks on, "Do you have any plan to address reputational
harm for all of this or do you think it's significant in the
long run?" Uh, nothing's insignificant. Um, in the short run,
uh, in the long run, the the big deal with these people are they
dude, the Drew Pavloo tweets are kind of going crazy right now.
Okay, the Drew Pavlau tweets are kind of going crazy. This guy's
going off. Hold on. You got if you if you know you know. If you
know you know. Okay.
Dude, the Drew the Drew Pavlu tweets are going crazy.
Me. [__] Yes. Just finished the best Pro Destiny
edit. This one has both of us dancing next to Malcolm X. Destiny.
I'm a ninja. Dude, hold on. There's an even better one. Dude,
this guy tweets too much. Holy [__] He tweets way
too much. Where is this other one? Hold on. Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? This one. For God's sake, why couldn't Destiny
just not be like this, bro? I made all these pro Destiny videos
with my face in them. Bro, that's rough. That's rough. That's
>> Issue with people like this when it comes to like cherryicical
all these people is that since these people have no reputation
and they have like nothing to lose, there's not much for me to
gain or to be gained by like trying to drag out any prolonged
fights with them. Same thing with >> Bro, he's been in
he just keeps coming. Dude, me and Auggie were joking about it
and then he appeared in the chat again. What is he talking about?
Like he doesn't engage. He absolutely engages. Why is he constantly
mentioning Cherry? Because he's a weirdo. He's a weirdo. He He
gets off on like violating people's consent and vi and flouting
it in their face. That's what he gets off on. He's a weirdo.
He's a loser. >> Pixie and Lauren. Like these people don't
really have anything in life. They don't have any money. They
don't have any reputation. >> He absolutely. By the way,
also it's insane to say he doesn't attack reputation either.
Like he hasn't spent the past like 6 months attacking our reputations.
He absolutely has. This is just a lie, right? Bro, this guy has
tanked his own reputation attacking our reputations. Dude, it's
it's wild that people will just believe this. People will just
believe this coke. >> Not much for me to gain or to be
gained by like trying to drag out any prolonged fights with them.
Same thing with Pixie and Lauren. Like these people don't really
have anything in life. They don't have any money. They don't
have any reputation. They don't have any careers. So like
>> uh guys listen, Jay-to has no money. That That's true.
Actually, Spruce Willis, it's up to you. Yes, you chatter to
change that for me. Okay, I need you guys to donate. You can
uh you can give subs kick. You can sub through Twitch. You sub
on Twitch with Twitch Primes. Okay, Twitch Primers. Any primers
out there? Any primers?
All right, you can donate. Exclamation point. Donate in the chat.
We'll give you the links. There's Streamlabs. There's Kickbot.
There's both. Okay, there's both all the time. Also, guys, by
the way, we're going to end on Twitch. So, I love you if you're
watching on Twitch. If you're watching on Twitch, head over to
kick
All right, kick.com/jstlk.
We're going to go live over there. Uh, we just don't get the
same amount of people on on Twitch. So, uh, head over join the
community on kick. It's where the chat's active. That's where
everybody is. Head over there >> and we'll see you in a
little bit. Bye-bye. Okay, we're off of Twitch. We can shut that
off.
>> Uh, somehow my alerts are still on. What is happening?
Hermster, thank you for the five. Thank you. Thank you. I didn't
unmute those alerts. There we go. Sorry, I didn't mute those
alerts, but the hamster, thank you very much for the five. Appreciate
the money, guys. You're helping us all fix it. You're helping
us all. You're helping me fix the problem Destiny just described.
I don't have the money. All right, I don't have the money. No,
I actually make good money. I appreciate all the support from
you guys. All right, I won't I won't lie about that. I won't
lie about that. He could totally come after me in a defamation
case if he wanted to. Um, mostly because he would lose. I don't
lie about this guy, but I'm saying that uh he could do it. He
could do it. There would be something to earn there, but he's
scared. He can't do it. like you're kind of like fighting with
somebody who has nothing to lose. So, it's not Yeah. So, there's
not much for me to go after there. I just kind of have to sit
through and wait for all the court process stuff to resolve itself.
What is the deadline for Abby to come to court and give her testimony?
Um, I don't know. Probably like December.
But if the if she doesn't do it, I mean, I don't know if she
technically has to do it. Like, she might not have to go to court
and they could just say she's willing to come in and testify,
but she it can't be found for deposition.
I think that might hurt their chances of summary judgement a
little bit, but it's hard to say.
>> that's not how he represented it before. He represented
like obviously it's illegal to do this. Obviously, I'm being
totally wrong. Obviously, the court will not look will not take
this into account right now. It's like, oh, but actually maybe
they will kind of like consider it a little bit. >> Like,
it's kind of funny that the Ethan Klein the big [__]
I'm not going to be able to find it. Oh, the huge Ethan Klein
case. >> I'm very mad, Cam. Very mad >> copyright
stuff. Like this thing had 121 items on their docket and then
I think mine is already up to like 115
and we haven't even technically entered discovery yet. Maybe
stop violating the orders. I don't know. Like that seems pretty
simple to like when they're like, "Hey, we're concerned that
this guy is trying to like violate, you know, hey, we're stealing
this person's uh identity away and Destiny goes, "Isn't that
Darius's roommate in his chat?" Right? When
when there's an order to steal a transcript and he goes on somebody's
stream and reads from the transcript verbatim, right? I'm sure
the Matt Hos and Ethan Klein lawsuit didn't have somebody acting
like a total child that could be sanctioned under the court system
every other week.
Yes. When you act like a child and you flout the court's orders
repeatedly, you get a lot of motions.
How is that difficult to understand? Sure, he did share part
of the transcript as well. Or from all appearances, he shared
part of the transcript. You're right. You're right. When you're
right, you're right. When you're right, you're right. 114 items.
>> I am aware Cyberdrifter. If you can send me a time stamp,
I'd check that out. >> I would say the reason is you fight
for the judgment so you can point at it in the future as the
whole situation not being what everyone claims it. Yeah, but
I like I don't even know how much it matters at this point because
I feel like the um I don't I don't think anybody actually cares
about the facts of it. Notice how like people change their mind
on things depending on what comes out. So So like as of a month
ago, everybody was basically like it doesn't really matter how
it resolves. We know that Desi is guilty anyway. It doesn't matter
what the court case does. Um I've So I'll just state my my position
here. Um I think they need to find something in discovery given
the evidence they have now. They need to find something in discovery.
him sending the pixie video to somebody else to stay within Cardi
or they'd need to be able to recover Aby's DMs. One of those
two things, right, where like where like he sent the video purportedly.
They need to be able to find these things and prove it to actually
get a judgment in their favor. If they don't find those things,
then I think the judgment would go in his favor, right? I do
think morally he's either way, but I understand a lot of people
don't see it that way. I think morally it's up either way. like
obviously he's the wrongdoing has been done but we we'll continue
but now when this road stuff pops out which has nothing to do
with this case also nice >> oh my I believe my my current
opinion is the same although I would say it's changed slightly
in that like I do think if this rose stuff goes like public and
gets put in newspapers and [__] people can Google
it and see it I do think that puts them at a disadvantage with
the jury okay jury's ain't nobody like a ain't nobody like so
an adult a 30 40 year old man who tries to [__] minor.
Okay, nobody likes that guy. Nobody likes them. >> U people
like, "Oh, actually the criminal stuff is really important now."
Actually, that's actually super important. Um, you know, Destiny,
I checked out the thread for the first time. I didn't realize
just how straightforward the call for Docsis were on people like
Mutton and Z. Yeah. And Dan and everything else. Um, so me and
>> they're like about as they're about as straightforward
as Destiny's call for Doc's. Yeah. Yeah. Probably >> talked
and we made a mutual decision to kind of like chill on just anything
else for a little bit. It sucks because obviously when you say
stuff like this, it makes them feel a little bit more empowered,
but like when people are literally going after people's children,
>> mutual mutual decision, mutual decision, >> and
stuff, it gets a little bit unhinged or going after like people's
like wives jobs and stuff. So, but I mean there's nothing Yeah.
when people are discover discovery will be clean. I think you've
prepared for that at Destiny. Well, the thing is there's just
not much to um there's just not much to really go over. >> Isn't
Destiny the one going after children? Destiny's the one who tried
to do who helped Kiwi Farms dock somebody who was a minor when
when he was them, right? I would say, yeah, that would suck if
people are going after um anyone's kids. You shouldn't drag like
minors into it. You don't have to do the collateral damage thing.
Okay. You don't have to do it. You don't have to do it for discovery
stuff. That's the issue. Um I'm 100% sure she's not going to
turn over to me relevant documents. I know she won't. She'll
lie about things like I've already seen stuff she's lied about.
like repeatedly telling people that Tinder is an ageverified
platform, right? Like telling people that Rose is an Only Fans
model. There are a lot of things that Destiny lies about and
apparently his audience just does not track these things whatsoever.
And I don't have anything to turn over much to her because I
I mean I haven't I mean, like I said, I would throw my DMs. I
haven't shared anything of us with anybody else. So, there's
just not much to go over there. I Yeah, like I said, at this
point, it's pretty much just dragging things out. Is it more
blatant now? I thought the posters always try to leave plausible
deniability.
Um, I think they tried to in the past, but I think uh, ever since
I did the whole skitso stream that had absolutely no credibility
whatsoever and was just me having a schizophrenic rambling session
and there was no validity to anything I said, 100% of course
not with all my paintings and everything. Um, when I I So again,
he could describe he he's trying to act like that stream is valid
because Kiwi Farms is bad. No, you weren't trying to prove Kiwi
Farms is bad. You're trying to prove connections between Kiwi
Farms and like me or Quimman or other people. And you did nothing
to prove that. And now you're going, "But Kiwi Farms is really
bad, guys." And just because they're bad, like I guess uh I guess
that proves everything else I said. You know, I definitely didn't
say anything true there. No, we all know Kiwi Farms doxing people
is bad. Nobody disagrees. Nobody disagrees. I did that. All of
them started to kick it off into like overdrive mode. So like
Queman and Justicle and everybody else on um not as much actually
spicy chat recently, but then on QB farm started to like move
into hyperdrive in terms of like calling for doces of people,
spreading docs of people, and then stepping up the harassment
of everybody else. Supposedly there are like a ton of people
calling into Connor's
>> he just he just did it again. Where did the where did
my harassment just show me a clip of me saying something, doing
something?
Where is any of this?
calling it to like Connor stream this morning and so >> is
that harassment? Connor literally invited these people on. Connor
said, "No, I want these people to come and chat here. I think
I have the right position. I want these people to come on stream."
Connor said that. How is that harassment? What are you looking
forward to in the future? Anything positive? Well, being through
all of this um being through all of this would be good. Drew
my super chat. Wait, hold on. Somebody said at Really? Wait.
All right, Destiny. really not trying to poke, but have you had
a perspective shift and change who you keep in your life/ pursuit
in regards to all the dramas here? Um, I went over all this a
few streams ago, but the big issue is I shifted the majority
of the content that I do in 2024.
So, like, >> totally, totally had Zen and Darius on multiple
times to fight, but you know, totally shifted the content, guys.
>> All of these people are
people from the past, unfortunately. Like now that these people
are just people that I don't really associate with anymore and
haven't for at least two years now. But the >> lying although
this is like from 2022 2023 it's just literally there are DMs
of me and him talking about the leaks right like he's saying
I didn't associate he's literally on my stream after those leaks
originally happened. I don't know why he's just lying two years
I haven't associated with these people in two years brother two
years and 6 months ago you're in my Discord trying to make Zoe
and Lav fight. What do you mean you haven't engaged with any
of this at all? Like
it hasn't been some taper off. Basically, what happened was the
the Sunday and Beckham videos dropped and a bunch of people walked
away from you. That's not you walking away from these people
or cutting these people out. There's people walking away from
you. >> So that keeps getting dug up from the >> Yes.
This was less than a year ago, Soystein. This was either I believe
this is December 2024 when he came on to yell at MC and say that
I couldn't have possibly slid my arm between her legs cuz she's
6' tall. because that somehow makes sense, right? That makes
sense to
>> The leaker, the leaker, Duterino, do your lawyers have
a working relationship with her lawyers or is it all handled
through emotions in the court? I mean, like we kind of do, but
her lawyers are
uh aggressive. Like, yeah. So, it's kind the communication is
not great.
What is the end goal for them? For who? >> Regretting his
voice. I don't know about that. Sorry. That's regretting his
voice talking about her lawyers, says Dead modem. No, I don't
know about that. I think um not talking about her lawyers, dude.
I just think he could have made like a reasonable offer to Pixie
and a decent chance a lot of this stuff goes away.
I think he's got to be just regretting his decision-m, right?
He's got to be. It's It's him completely. The released a video
where he called the cops on you based. Okay.
>> Oh, boy.
Well, that's where that comes in. Okay. That's where that comes
in.
>> Jesus. Jesus Christ. That's rough.
All right, that is that is rough. And here's the thing. Destiny
just spent so much time trying to say Willie's a target and propping
him up and going like, "Willie's smart. Willy smart. Willie Mac's
smart." Right? Because Willie Mac was one of the only people
coming close to siding with him, right? For so long. Willy smart.
Willy smart. Guys, go watch Willie's video. Willie seemed really
reasonable here. And then Willie Mack drops a video. Uh,
I called the cops on Destiny. I believe he has child on his computer.
I called the cops.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. There's
no way he just said that. Jacob, what?
Yeah. So, it's kind The communication is not great. What is the
end goal for them? For who? >> Wait, he he blanks. This
would be where he got linked the video, right? He would have
gotten linked the video and and paused here and just been like,
"Fuck me." Where the released a video where he called the cops
at you based. Okay. Apparently, he just finished saying Jacob
says he just finished saying that uh nothing else is going to
drop. That was it.
>> How do you solve all this? Does it just die off or is
there >> We got a plan, right, Destiny? Destiny, we got
a plan. Is there Isn't there someone you can debate? Destiny,
can you debate like the the chief of police? Destiny, can you
debate like the like debate Cash Patel? Debate Cash Patel. Debate
him now.
An action you can take to stop the snarkers. Um, I think that
the biggest I think that the biggest issue that you have to deal
with is that um, like I said before, like I went over this, I
did like a huge skitso stream or whatever, but there is a there's
like a >> Wait, who what
am I not speaking English? What what did he just say? >> Yeah,
like I said before, like I went over this, he did like a huge
skit stream or whatever, but there is >> Hassan maybe.
Wait, am I missing who he just Maybe I'm just totally missing
it. >> Is there an action you can take to stop the snarkers?
Um, I think that the biggest I think that the biggest issue that
you have to deal with is that um, like I said before, like I
went over this, I did like a huge skitso stream or whatever,
but there is a there's like a place on the internet where people
can do kind of like weird if you want to, but the problem now
is large content creators.
I don't know if it's only on the left. It feels like it's only
on the left. I don't know why. Maybe it's not. >> Who is
he talking about that? It must be Hassan. I think it's it's got
to be. There's a huge content creator pipeline up through Hassan
now where all of it will just get mega ultra amplified
by the like the largest content creators on the left basically.
So there's like
uh unfortunately here's the thing. How can Destiny possibly be
upset with this when he constantly him and Dan constantly take
any tiny thing Hassan does and they amplify that as much as they
possibly can. They take it to the the
they don't take it to like the limit of like, oh, they still
can like plausibly be operating good faith. No, they are totally
bad faith. They they interpret it in the worst way you possibly
can without being accused of outright lying, outright like fabricating
stuff about Hassan. And they've been doing this for months. And
now they're shocked that actual credible evidence, factual evidence
that Desi was minor comes out and he's like, "I can't believe
Hassan would amplify this. I can't believe Hassan would do this
to me, guys. It's so weird that Hassan would do this to me. Can
you believe it? Yeah, I I can totally believe it. Yeah, you've
been lying about him for long enough that of course he's going
to do it to you the second he can. Yes, of course I can believe
that. And I'm not talking about criticisms of Assan's Israel
positions or something. I'm talking about like him going to that
brothel. I'm talking about like uh him going to that diddy party
at Coachella or whatever high on mushrooms. I'm talking about
misrepresenting those things to try to make him look like a or
a criminal of some kind, right? I'm talking about that. There's
way more evidence of Destiny this minor than there is of anything
to do with Assan's malfeasants at the the brothel or anything.
There's way more evidence than the Isan throwing a rave party
tonight. He might be. I I suspect he's not because I've not gotten
an invitation yet. Snow Lucille. Snow Lucille says Hassan's throwing
a rave party tonight. I don't think so cuz I haven't got an invitation
yet. I'm pretty sure Hassan would hook me up. Okay. I'm pretty
sure.
>> Like until that stops, there's nothing that you can
do about it. But like now they have every incentive to go like
as hard as possible, you know?
>> Dude, this guy built his whole network of people amplifying
every piece of negative Hassan news that they could. And he's
like, "Well, you know, I I guess I'm just now guys. I guess Hassan's
just going to run with this." Yeah, he is. Of course he is. What
about Lauren blatantly doxing you the other day? Something actionable?
Again, there's nothing actionable because doxing is not illegal
and reputationally she's like invincible. There's like >> doxing
is
I I I believe that doxing can fall under um like cyber bullying
laws in Florida. It probably has some action you could take.
>> There's like nothing that you can do. She has no reputation
to harm online. So, there's like nothing that you can actually
do about it. They're dropping a Maxwell interview. >> Okay,
let's take a quick let's take a quick break from this quick palette
cleanser. Okay, we going to we going to do a little Hassan review.
Little Hassan tent for old time sake, guys. Little Hassan tent.
>> This is uh this is Hassan watching the fully Willy video.
Okay, >> it's because he continued to write. I didn't know
this until way later, but the video she recorded with other guys,
the file names are like screen recording blah blah blah. And
then he shows me his on the top of a video clip and says her
boyfriend was recording these on Skype calls. That's absolutely
insane to Hassan watch this. Of course, Hassan watched it. Yes,
of course he did. Think about him doing all of this if she was
>> Wait, what? Oh, I get it. I get it, Osel. I get it.
>> This is insane to me because he's saying Rose's boyfriend
recorded CP while sending me a of the alleged CP. So, I asked
to confirm if he just did that. If you were sending me this,
I'm guessing you still have that video. Destiny replies, "Depends."
Dude, I feel like I feel like Assan in the back of his head a
little bit has to just be like I I feel like he's going to hit
get hit by the disbelief. Like, there's no way. We'll see if
he just laughs and like rolls with it. But I feel like a little
bit Han's got to be like, "Dude, there's no way he said these
have to be fake." Like it's I I can't reiterate enough how weird
it is that this guy just keeps doing like this and it seems like
I don't know what point this doesn't just this just has to become
his character, right? He's like the LCA who absolutely like tells
on himself all the time. This is just his character now. Every
time you think there's no way this would be way too dumb for
Destiny to do, there is nothing too dumb for Destiny to do. Destiny
is the guy who gave extra evidence to his Alogs to find the minor
he was. This is like who he is now. He is 2025's local of the
year. Not close. Not even close. There's nobody coming anywhere
near that. Okay. >> On why you're asking, but yes, I created
copies of all of our messages and everything when that court
case started. Just to be clear, he's admitting to having alleged
CP. >> Why does why does this dude think
that this is like a good defense? I mean, I don't think that
that Willie Slop Show actually gives a about anything. I'll be
honest with you. I think he's like he's a mercenary and uh and
I think he's just reading the room and and realizing that this
is a sinking ship that he must jump cuz he was like actively
defending. >> Incredibly accurate call from Hassan. Let's
go. sweeping for him uh for Destiny for quite a while even after
like the initial uh accusations of the court cases took place
like he was like kind of critical of him but not really. He was
critical of him in a way where it was like still in defense of
him. Um he has utilized uh Destiny's community >> to make
multiple fairly successful videos on people like myself and many
other uh enemies of Destiny. He is definitely a fixture of that
slop tuber community that we talk about. Like these guys literally
looked at Israel's >> [__] slop tubers guys
>> of the Palestinian population and thought this is a
great opportunity for us to farm some some drama clicks and uh
and unfortunately there are a lot of not very intelligent people
who have taken their note. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's >> like
the walls are closing in. Listen, we can talk about
I need Hassan to stop focusing on the forest of and focus on
the tree. Okay, we can talk about Israel later. Focus on destiny.
Okay, >> case started. Just to be clear, by the way, that's
a little humor downloaded on his computer. He literally has the
video open as I'm talking to him. I go, "Bro, there's been allegations
at least since my last video that she was underage and you still
have potential CP of her." He replies, "I have an obligation
to preserve relevant evidence, etc." So, I created backups of
all of the important/relevant convers Oh no
guys, I've got some bad news. Okay, got some bad news. We thought
we thought it was, you know, Destiny just said it was mutually
agreed. Okay, Dan has to step back from anything else. All right,
Dan has to step back. Um, it was mutually agreed upon. It's just
it's like a short-term, guys. Apparently, Dan's now offering
refunds on anything else subs.
Maybe he feels like the money the money might not be very clean.
Okay. Wow. For anyone that paid for a sub, especially a yearly
sub, I'll be handing refunds shortly. And I already disabled
new signups. Thank you for all your support over the years. It
means a ton to me. Now, that doesn't sound like a shortterm
a short-term thing. Okay. It doesn't sound that way to me. Does
it sounds like he is taking a step back from a certain community.
All right. That's what it sounds like to me. Wow.
I'm just pointing this out because as much as we all knew yesterday
what Dan was saying, Destiny went on his stream today and said,
"No, Dan just feels like pressured." So, he's going to like take
a little break. You know, we mutually agreed. We should take
a little break or something. Mutually agreed upon. Airite new
co-host.
Let's go. Not so Connor and Destiny. That's the new anything
else podcast. Let's go. I think we can get it done, guys. I think
that's the new lineup.
Come on. Wouldn't that go hard? Didn't this dang guy never refund
the people who he is willing to sell legal CSGO cheats? I don't
know, man. I have no idea about that. Long before he deletes
all the VODs. I hope somebody's got that West VOD.
I hope somebody's got it cuz I really want that West VOD where
Wes talks about Destiny cosplaying as a
in girls DMs. That VOD. I want that VOD. Someone get me that
VOD. Call Call the new podcast Any Bridge. Like, we will take
any bridge at this point. The DG community is Atlantis. Okay,
they need any bridge to any land mass. All right, it's taking
it on water, please. Any bridge. Any bridges. Any bridge, guys.
Any bridges.
Oh, that's good [__] Let's go. Oh, whoops. Whips
whips. I forgot. We're on our we're on we we we go we go between
the two auras. Okay.
The defender aura and the aura. I'm starting to really enjoy
the quite a bit more. I'm not going to lie to you guys. Okay,
>> he continues. I don't think I'm allowed to delete it,
lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/destroying evidence.
And I reply, talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me. Who keeps
this sort of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing if
they're supposed to or not? Isn't that something you want to
confirm? I continued, "You just let me know you have CP videos
saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she was
underage. You still have them. Do you see how [__]
this is? So now I've confirmed that this guy has child on his
computer. In my 8 years of reaching out to people over allegations,
I've never had anyone admit that to me. The last message he sent
me was one, I don't even know 100% of her age was legitimately
less than 18 when these were taken. So basically, he's not 100%
sure if he has child on his computer. He's just 99% sure. Got
it. Two, I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to preserve stuff
related to my court case. I've talked about it with my lawyer
already, specifically with regards to the Rose stuff. So, we
went >> Oh, no way.
Wes has the full VOD up on his channel.
Wes got the full unlisted VOD up on his channel. Let's go. Uh,
can I go ahead and download this really quickly before it suddenly
disappears? Let's uh let's get that uh let's get that downloaded
before it goes anywhere. Okay. I'm not saying Wes would delete
it, but let's say it gets copyright struck or something. We don't
want to see that. All right. We don't want to see that. >> Riy
donated $3. This timeline was not in my horoscope this morning.
>> Uh Riyle, thanks for the three. I appreciate it. All
right, we uh we've got that downloading. All right, let's get
back to >> From I don't know if I could delete this to
my lawyer says it's totally fine to keep. I don't know the law,
but the idea that his lawyer would tell him to hold on to CP
for a civil case just doesn't seem likely to me, I don't know.
Law Tube can figure that out. Three, if something were to come
out of this, I don't know if I'd want to wipe everything and
not have something to turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically,
whenever a political creator is about to give a hypothetical,
you know you're about to can figure that out. Three, if something
were to come out of this, I don't know if I'd want to wipe out.
>> If something were to come out of this, wait,
we just got like proof that she's 17. At least we don't even
know 100% if her age is legit. We do know that. And by the way,
he's basically like accepted the leaks at this point. If something
were to come out of this, are you saying that you would be willing
to bury this? that you you assume that this is a child trafficker,
this solo guy, and you're willing to like let nothing come out
of this. Really, dude, everything, and not have something to
turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically, whenever a political
creator is about to give a hypothetical, you know, you're about
to hear some weird, if hypothetically her boyfriend or whatever
was actually trafficking her or getting her to other dudes on
video for him. And if there was ever some kind of investigation,
>> he's like a serial killer keeping trophies. And then
after after he gets caught, they're like, "Why did you keep all
these teeth?" And he's like, "Well, you know, just in case the
police investigated, I wanted them to have something. I wanted
them to have something to go on, guys. You know, just in case
something comes of all these murders that I've done,
you know,
into that, am I hurting the chance of looking into him by deleting
all of this stuff?" Oh, so now the reason he's keeping the se
>> Yeah. No, is there's a justifiable reason for it? It's
he actually has a a the uh utmost uh highest morals at all times.
Wow. From the guy who has actively uh debated uh the the ethics
of uh ethical CP ethical cam
uh comes an opportunity for him to have that uh in in his uh
in his hard drive. >> He is because of >> Destiny
be like I'm a white hat. Actually, you don't understand. the
hypothetical criminal case that he is not.
Okay. White hat goes so unbelievably hard.
Dude, I solicited cam from minors so that I can prove that they're
being trafficked.
No way.
Oh my god. Pursuing it all. Okay. Maybe these reasons are legally
sound advice that came from his lawyer. Maybe he's lying and
just saying anything to make it sound better to me. I don't know.
I'm not a lawyer. I just know this guy's admitting to having
CP in my DMs. 60 gigabytes according to him. Ser, >> what
does white hat mean? White hat is like white hat hacker is somebody
who hacks things and then exposes how they hacked things to the
people they just hacked without doing anything, without taking
any money just to make the world a better place just to make
it so like your data is safer or somebody like that. Okay, white
hat will be the same concept. They're just soliciting CESAM to
like make the world a better place. Okay. They're they're soliciting
CISM with the highest regard for like morals and principles.
White hat.
>> Yeah. Destiny. Destiny be like, "Excuse me, what if
there was a nuke that was about to go off in New York City and
the only way to stop it is to insert a USB with CSAM into a into
my computer and watch what then?" And then of course the the
intellectual titans uh cult of sickop fans will literally look
at that and go
>> that's an amazing argument. I never thought about it
like that. Actually
>> dude he's actually winning so hard. He's winning so
hard.
>> Far right to do so. That's one of the most like ridiculous
aspects of this uh this entire
uh situation beyond the the the criminal element. beyond the
fact that like there are still people who are so deluded.
If your whole
if your entire
uh fandom revolves around you making the best argument possible
and ritualistically humiliating your interlocutors in the marketplace
of ideas and you can't even come up with like a convincing counternarrative
here,
then how what do you have? You have nothing that that remains.
Like a couple of the a couple of the reasons why
>> He's still lying about the log about logs of Rose telling
him she's 19. They don't exist. Oh, have we not seen those? Has
he not provided those? Cuz he's definitely said, "Oh, well, she
gave me reasons to believe." You know what I think this is, Yaon?
I think this is where he asks for like ID or something. I think
that was her response there. And I think he can't show those
DMs and prove that they are real. I want to say it's something
like something along those lines. One second. >> Is blocks
of Lauren Southern to her and like this is so embarrassing. I'm
like confiniding in >> and she doesn't deny it. It's not
>> I don't know if she denies it, but that's what he's
calling >> Okay. Okay. >> apparently. Uh sorry. When
uh when he talks to Lauren Southern when he dumps those logs
to her, she says or sorry, he says, "I can't believe I'm trauma
dumping to a 19-year-old." And she I believe doesn't deny or
I've not seen logs of her denying. Believe I remember those.
I'm not talking to myself. I'm Yes. Cherry Cherry is here. Yes.
Yes. Sorry. When I said I was talking to myself and doing a voice
earlier, that was a lie. That was like me joking cuz I thought
it was obvious. But if it's not obvious, yes, Cherry's here right
now. Second Mike when? Uh, I don't know. I don't know. We'll
see. We'll see. We'll see. We're back to the Hassan video. Let's
go. >> Still hold on to this idea that like Destiny's a
force for good. Actually, even though he's just a little bit
of a gooner, was because one, um, he is actively dradicalizing
people, right? He is so effective at dradicalizing people. I've
seen no evidence of this. Okay. I've seen no evidence of this
whatsoever, especially because like he still holds a lot of reactionary
perspectives. He just says, you know, you can say the end is
a white guy and and [__] on marginalized people all
the >> god damn it. I still believe I still believe we
had the right argument on that. Okay. I I still believe that
argument 100%. >> Time except, you know, you just have
to vote Democrat while doing so. Um and and not only that, but
also he can't even help his own son. If he was a better father
to his own son, his own son wouldn't have turned into a
so clearly failed on that front demonstrabably. And the other
idea that people love him is because he is this like intellectual
warlord, a giant that can best any anyone in the marketplace
of ideas no matter uh how how incredible their intellect might
be, right? he can go toe-to-toe with intellectuals
uh that are subject matter experts and still defeat them in the
marketplace of ideas. That also was a abject failure with the
conversation that took place between him and obviously Norm Finkelstein.
Even though his cult still deluded themselves into believing
that he didn't make a fool of himself in that
>> They I mean Norm made a fool of everybody in that process.
Norm was not there to debate. Although Norm was funny. Okay.
>> Okay. But especially now, even if it's like even if
you're viewing this from the perspective of drama,
okay, even if you're viewing this from the perspective of drama,
the way that he has actually dealt with this this this criminal
incident is so
so stupid.
I brought up one of the examples yesterday. Okay. >> Oh,
let's go. Let's go. I can feel what I can feel when I'm about
to be brought up. I can feel what I'm about to be brought up.
Okay. Lawyer Wait, what? Debate a lawyer. >> He's about
to pull up my Twitter. >> I don't know what you're what
you're even saying right now. I I >> I'm typing typing
to debate a lawyer. >> 15 seconds. I need you to pull my
tweet up on screen. >> I don't even know what you're
>> 14, 13, 12. What I'm trying to say is >> with
respect to with respect to what >> um what what DE's been
trying to do in the last couple of days is he's like flailing
around and trying to defend >> He's gone back to his old
>> uh number one. What about Hassan? >> Okay, that's
always the I thought it was coming. I thought it was coming has
helped him. >> I can tell he's talking about it. >> Ridiculous.
Uh no matter how [__] up something he's saying is,
he can always turn around and say, "Well, what about Hassan?"
Okay. Well, that rip cord doesn't work here. Okay. It's clearly
not working because this is like a [__] criminal
thing that he's doing and that hasn't worked. So, he has also
started the process once again or never really stopped the process
of victim blaming uh specifically going after Pixie who is in
a court case as a victim of the distribution of revenge.
Okay. And he's he's turning around and and uh you know attacking
Pixie and anyone he can get his hands on. anyone he can like
belittle. But even in those counter arguments, even though in
those deflections, like they're so sick, >> bro. He like
started setting, okay? Like at some point here, he realized that
like he can't even really go after like so he he does still go
after all these people, but like he he reaches so far down like
Eli Eli B, she's got like how many followers on Twitter does
she have? like he started harassing her openly and like trying
to call her insane and like all of all of her replies to him.
He like goes and like totally directs his oh, she's got 2900.
Never mind. She's like roughly the same size as my Twitter account.
But still, it's like a small Twitter account that just asks like
good questions when he comes and like lies about, right?
And he's like taken to like going to her replies and going like
she's insane. She takes antiscychotics, which by the way, wholesale
fabricated, just creative writing about her. He doesn't know
anything she takes. He doesn't know anything like that. She doesn't,
right? But he just fabricates it. and the his like ability to
take the like insults in his audience and weaponize them just
by being like look at this insane horror, right? And all of them
just click in immediately. Dude, quote tweeted me. Wait, who
quote tweeted you? Simply substance. Was it Hassan? Who quote
tweeted you? Let's go in any case. Okay, >> Keep going.
>> He's just He's going after anybody he can. He will just
he will attack anyone. And make no mistake, that's what this
is about, right? Whoops. Not this. Although also this
uh this that's what this is about, right? It'll just come down
to other communities, especially this one. Not being [__]
about everything, right? How do we stop how do we stop these
people from talking about Destiny? It'll take you guys not being
Why do I have to go and show you guys how to attack these people?
Why can't any of you pick up the pick up the swords and do it
yourselves?
That's what he's doing here, right? It's going to take you guys
participating. He's like actively trying to rile up his audience
to at most charitably harass these people least charitably obviously
like trying to get somebody to uh to do violence, right? Uh Destiny,
why say why or sorry when you say not being what do you mean
exactly? Genuinely curious. Uh Redhead, you know what I mean,
baby? Redhead says, "Destiny, in my heart of hearts, I do." And
I'm not going to say the last part. 07.
So when you leave it open-ended like that, it seems like he's
saying there's nothing I can do. Okay. It's going to take you
guys doing something. There's nothing I can do. It's going to
take you guys doing something. Wow. >> Elections are so
unimaginably
silly. Like he'll just be like, "Why does nobody care about the
person who uh uh potentially filmed uh this this CSAM?" It's
like, >> "We don't know who that is." >> What the
[__] do you mean? Why does >> you have all
the information? >> Nobody care about the person who filmed
the cam. Like, nobody knows that person. You know that person.
You have direct involvement with that person. You should be the
one who cares. That's not an accident. What do you mean?
>> Hassan's following all of this. Okay. I need to look
at my followers in the past like 24 hours. Hassan's definitely
on board right now. There's some Hassan alt in the last 24 hours
of my new follows. He's in there for sure. >> Well, I'm
just the NFC Sam as opposed to the person who procured it. Okay.
Why the do you think that's a that's an argument that actually
maintains your innocence? That just means there's another guy
out there who's also an awful piece of [__] That
doesn't make any sense. You can't turn around and be like, "Well,
your your honor, I may have purchased it, but someone else made
it." And from what I understand, the only reason why they figured
out that this person that he was actually sending the revenge
of others to
>> in solicitation of CSAM and even uh actively trying
to to
traffic this minor. Okay, both are different crimes. That person
was 17. And the reason why people figured out that that person
was 17, it's because he leaked additional information about them
to try to get them doxed by KF. Yes. Yes. Say it. >> Because
he flexed on the haters to to reveal information about this person
seemingly so that people he goed people into figuring out who
this person was to identify uh who this person was and then they
did. It makes no sense. Anybody else? Anybody else feeling like
their their Cabal badge flashing? I just I when when the Cabal
is like fully in sync, I could just feel the the badge is like
flashing against my chest right now. It's like a heart. It's
like I put it over my heart and it connects Hassan's heartbeat
to mine and everybody in the cabal our heartbeat is one. Okay.
He just I can just feel it. Okay. I can feel it. It's actually
a little lighter. It's like this. It's like this. I think so.
We're all We're all connected. We're all on the same page. We
all know exactly what to say. Yes. Yes. I feel it. >> And
now that they did and now he's
>> Okay. I I think this is uh DG coded right here. Did
not make this. It's a It's a joke about our hearts being connected.
Okay. Our hearts are all in the right place. The correct place.
The righteous place. >> Just yesterday, he lied by claiming
there was nothing to give to the police. In yet another shocking
case of self-sabotage. Omni.
>> Let's go. Let's go. Let's [__]
claim yesterday he had no evidence to give to the police regarding
Rose. Today Willie Mro posted a video explicitly detailing evidence
that Destiny gave him including file names perpet sent by Rose.
Destiny goes on to convent confess that all that he has made
copies of not just his friend's messages but all with with Rose
and all attachments. Would he be incapable of going to the police
with these files? If you send me this, I'm guessing you still
have that video. He says
he says he's not sure if she was under 18 when the video was
taken. The video title just commented on a date that is obviously
before is claimed to be her 18th birthday. As if this couldn't
get any more bizarre, Destiny goes on to tell Willie that the
reason he is preserving this evidence is to help a potential
investigation.
The exact thing he told Eli B again he wasn't able to do. Oh
no,
Hassan. I'm tell I'm going to communicate again to Hassan through
the void. Okay, our thoughts are connected. I can communicate
to him. Hassan, you have to unblock Eli. Okay, you have to unblock
her. You have to unblock her now. Hassan, you have to unblock
her now. Hassan, unblock her now.
>> Oh, incredible stuff. Stephen, bro, at its most like
it there is also like obviously a permanent victimhood narrative
here at the heart of everything. It's like he distributes revenge
that he has filmed both consensually and unconsensually of other
people to a random person on Discord in an effort to like [__]
that person because he wants to [__] the person.
Turns out the person is also 17, which is, you know, extra insane
and criminal. >> Hassan's still not even got the full narrative.
It's not even just a random person. It's a person he found on
a non-ageverified platform and initiate seemingly initiated contact
with. Maybe they initiated contact. I'm not sure it matters,
but it was on a non-ageverified platform. She doesn't sell any
on age verified platforms.
Seems kind of curious since those are by far the most lucrative
platforms that exist. Very >> Okay. But even in that process,
like he's been able to try and and present himself as the real
victim here. He's like, "Oh, well, my got leaked, too." It's
like, "Bro, why were you sending it out? What the do you mean?
Why were you distributing it? Why were you filming it without
the consent of both parties? Why were you distributing it without
the consent of of all parties involved? This doesn't make any
sense whatsoever."
But clearly, even though plenty of people initially were like,
"Oh man, I'm actually very upset about this." They still turned
around and eventually found that there was a good reason to protect
Destiny here, to to defend Destiny here, to cuz he's like his
enemies are so much worse than him.
Me, >> ironically enough, that's what they literally think.
>> That I'm like actively terrorizing the country. I'm
a hater of America. I want to sabotage America. I'm a terrorist.
And he's the only bull work against like >> I think he
hates a lot of parts of America for sure. I don't know if he
hates the concept of America. I don't know if that's quite true.
>> Growing communism in the country that they've been deluded
into thinking is like a a reasonable force to reckon with or
even a scary one at all. Yeah. It turns out Pediny reminds me
of Onision, but the debate lore version. Yeah, Onision was at
least like a convincing enough debater. He he probably would
have been able to maintain his career, I guess. Oh, no way. There's
no way. When was this? Hold on. Did Darius come in and like start
talking [__] What? What? What are these Darius loss?
Hold on. I I hate to do this to you guys because I do love Hassan.
Okay, but emergency Darius log reading. What in the is this real?
Is this real chat? This probably memes, but I'm going to read
it anyway cuz it's uh it's very funny. I didn't see this. Destiny,
I'll take after hours, but you have to host me and stop being
scared of me. Destiny, put me on the auto host. Oh, I don't know
why I still have this alarm. I still have this alarm set. I still
have that stupid alarm set. Sorry, Dusty. You have to host me
and stop being scared of me. Isn't it crazy that Destiny is more
willing to be on a stream with food shops than Darius?
Like, say what you will about Darius.
Okay, say what you will. He's better than like a Isn't he? Is
Isn't he? I hope so.
What does Destiny know about Darius that he's like, "No, I'm
going to go hang out with this." Destiny, you host Mr. Mutin,
but not me despite me being a better friend. Destiny, I think
I'm just going to backstab you because that seems to be the only
way to get your attention. All right, let's just start leaking
about Destiny since he won't say.
Destiny, comed on Sushi's feed. Next leak. You got 30 seconds.
All right, Steven leak number two since you're pissing me off.
Desi, stop posting reals in address. Not hosting me, but hosting
food shops and Mr. Mootin. No, I'm not. Desty, you keep ignoring
me and I eventually will turn to Jtock.
This ninja. All right, you donalled me for the last time. See
you in Arizona, Destiny. Bro, I don't know. I don't know if that's
fake. I don't know if like the like I think this might be real
rage. Dude, Darius has Darius has done a lot of weird things.
You could say that Dung Devil, but the optics the optics still
land in favor of Darius. I'm almost positive. Okay. You can't
have the food chops clip floating around of her saying she wants
her legs wrapped around a 13-year-old girl or a 13-year-old girl's
legs wrapped around her, whichever way that went. You can't say
that [__] in in full honesty
and then have better optics than Darius, okay? or basically anyone.
I'm just I'm just saying. Okay. I'm just saying. Sorry. I I had
not seen those Darius logs. That's an important clip right there.
We like that. That was funny. That was funny. I remember when
me and Jay talk with link Darius streams in DG. Some of those
Darius streams were kino. Dude, that said 12. She said 12. Oh,
my mistake, guys. Little misinfo on my part. She didn't say 13-year-old.
She said 12-year-old. We didn't even get up to the teens. Okay,
we got stuck in the pre-teens. Oh, pause. Did not mean to say
that phrasing. That's something food shops would say. All right,
we continue. Have you already covered Destiny seeing the Willy
Mack video getting posted? Yeah, we covered his like response
where he saw that it came out. That was just that was what we
just went through. >> He is trying to flip over once again
in this process, too. He's like, "Well, I was just duped. I was
duped by a 17-year-old. I'm actually the real victim here." Yeah.
Here's the here's the other victim here. Primary victim. For
God's sake, why can Destiny just not be like this? >> Okay,
this got to go back to doing politics. Okay. Do not take my audience
for me, Hassan. Don't do it. Hassan, go back to politics. Go
back to politics now. Hassan >> Disney videos with my face
in them. >> That's some funny, dude. The Drew the Drew
Pavlu tweets are so funny. >> Wake up call for a lot of
people in his cult. This should be a wakeup call for a lot of
his orbiters
that maybe everything he was saying was lie from the start. If
he is, if he always operated this way and you found him to be
a charismatic figure, perhaps you were deluded into into shaping
your world view
around the personal vendettas of a
a sociopath.
I I feel like I feel like Hassan watches the content. Okay. I
feel like Hassan watches the content.
Now, Hassan's got his flaws. Okay. He's got major flaws. He absolutely
does.
But but this is just true. A lot of people formed a lot of opinions
based on this guy's personal vendettas. And I think it's important
to you as a person that you reset on those and try again. And
if they really do suck, then you'll just figure out they suck
again really quickly.
But there's no harm. There's no harm in doing that reset. Trust
me, if you take two weeks or a month off of saying that Hassan
is the worst person, right? And then you rediscover that Hassan
is the worst person, that's not going to hurt anybody. That's
not going to hurt anybody. I promise you that's not going to
hurt anybody. Okay? Assad is bad.
I promise you though, you take like two weeks or a month off,
you're not The world won't end. The world won't end. Assad has
said messed up stuff. He has indeed. I'm not saying he's never
said messed up stuff. I'm saying that possibly the level of vitrial
some people directed him is not quite like up to the level of
his actions. Possibly.
>> pathic villain and >> I'm just arguing if you
think he's like one of the top five worst people in America.
I'm just saying like maybe that might be top 50. That might be
top 1,000. Okay. He might not be in the top 1000. He might still
be really bad but just not in the top 1,000. You don't have to
think he's one of the most harmful people in America. I I I feel
like that's a little too much. It's just a little too much. That's
all. And I know that de cult deprogramming takes a lot of effort,
but considering that this is considering that this is just like
someone you have no interest in, someone who you don't know at
all, when you find out that they're like a freak, this is a good
point of of severance. The easiest exit ramp of all time to be
like, "Yeah, >> and Assad is bad. >> This is my breakoff
point." Perhaps the thing the thing that he was saying and doing
all along might have been might have been to serve his own personal
agendas to serve his own personal uh vengeance mission. Everything
he does he does for himself. It's not like he's like hiding it
either. That's it. So, you know, I I I welcome people finally
coming to that conclusion on their own. It took far too long.
But but it is it is wild. Yeah. Man has stupid take and claims
Destiny isn't a Destiny responds by saying no actually I am a
what the >> trapped in a cave looking for diamonds. That's
funny. I'm in the same cave looking for miners. >> What?
What is even >> this is better if you understand the dynamics
of play. Okay.
So gross that >> I don't even touch that. That's my third
rail. You know I don't Oh god.
I feel like I'm staring into the void and it's staring back at
me. That guy is also a Jesus Christ. It's just the ultimate debate
pervert tactic. Neuter your opponent by admitting to being a
I know but like I just don't I don't his subre is deleting posts
about it. His cult will never snap out of this. I don't think
there is I mean I think this is uh this has entered a different
stage now especially considering that some of his most like loyal
uh uh community members and orbiters self a self-described term
by the way >> are actively jumping ship
and his community is marginal it's ultimately >> son is
like one of the first orbiters I don't know why he always does
this weird >> very loyal but it's it's tiny and it only
works when there are other
seemingly objective other uh external forces that he can deploy
like Willie Slop Show is a great example of this this Okay, I
think we pause here. We go back to the Destiny VOD. Okay, we're
going to go back to the Destiny VOD now. Keep checking this out.
I think we just hit the point where he figures out that Willie
did his he talks about Dan. All right, he's Wait, he's going
to mention you? Wait, he just mentioned he just spent like five
minutes covering my tweets. Hold on. >> To be another one
of his orbiters. He he jumped ship when the when the uh revenge
stuff came out. Many other examples as
>> Made a moral decision to leave. Not really jump ship.
Not really jump ship. Okay. Listen, >> but like very clearly
very clearly it's it's now come to that point. So >> sure.
It's also jumping ship. It is. Sure. Sure. I think that there
is going to be even more push back from people that are around
him. His mods are deleting stuff. Yeah, I know. Uh that's not
surprising to me at all. I'll be honest with you. That's not
uh even remotely surprising to me at all. I mean, they're Look
at LSF. They also
like they're very good at brigading Reddit. I'll give them that.
They're very good at brigading Reddit and they're very good at
like creating an environment of plausible deniability,
but there are certain things that you just can't continue doing
when the crime is far too severe.
Uh it usually it usually leads to um it usually leads to people
even in your own community going, "No, that's going to that's
going to tarnish your good reputation forever." And it should.
The only reason why I think it's gotten to this position is because
there was never accountability for far too long. He just kind
of got Okay. All right. Yeah. He's I He's just going to say things
that we've uh that we're also saying. We're all saying. Okay.
Even if I don't like Destiny, it is crazy. Sorry. Me human says,
"Even if I don't like Destiny, it is crazy how much people spend
time to try to bring him down. But it seems like maybe his own
enemy.
He may be his own enemy and has created the world he's living
in." Yeah, not to be the son, not to do the son bit, but yes,
exactly. Um, listen, there's a quote in that thread, okay, from
yesterday.
There's a quote in that thread. I I read it and I thought it
was very funny. Okay,
Destiny's made the critical mistake of making two invincible
enemies. Okay, one of them is me. The other is himself. Okay,
he is his own worst enemy. Now, I didn't say that. So, when I
say me there doesn't necessarily apply, but it also applies to
me. So, that that is what it is. Okay.
>> We're pausing on Hassan. We're going back to the Destiny
VOD here. Okay. He has just found out that Willie Mack has put
the dagger in his back. All right. Let's see how he reacts. This
is silence after hearing. >> You can actually >> Oh,
no. Right here. Right at the end of this silence. I think right
at the end of this silence, right? He says the Willie Mack bit.
Could it hurt to find another job? Why? I mean, she's already
Maybe not. He had just figured out who the Willie Mack was from
again. Okay. Uh, so he had, why did I say that? He had just been
told that William Mack dropped the video saying that he had sent
child >> crashed out as being a public defender. >> And
so now she's like trying to raise money on that whatever website
online. >> Oh, he's talking about Lauren de Laguna.